Oh, oh, don't look at that.
Don't look at that.
Okay, members, I will have to change the password to the
Zomboid server.
Leaked.
Okay, give me a sec.
Members, I am going to change the password to the Zomboid
server.
Just to let everyone know I'm not I'm not smart Alright,
give me a sec I shall change it now Don't worry Guys, those
are like I'll be very transparent with you guys Okay, let's
spread it Spread the word Spread the word to the server
Spread the word that we are changing the password let them
all know the password is gonna change okay all right i'll
post i'm gonna change it now actually i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm all over the place literally we just had a zomboid um a
zomboid stream um um like like a couple of hours ago and i
forgot to uh okay okay all right i changed the password I am
restarting.
Spread the word in the server right now that I'm restarting.
I'm restarting the server.
I'm the leaker.
It's me.
I was the leaker all along.
All right.
I am restarting the server now and I shall post the new
password.
That is my bad.
That is, that is my.
Look, I was going through a lot, okay?
I was trying to figure out like I forgot to download the
game and it's not looking so great guys The reason why is
that it's still at 1% I've been having this game downloading
for since like Since 445 and usually it's like super fast.
It's super fast because I have fiber But for some reason
it's still at 1% so I'm a little worried.
Okay, let me Hello, everyone.
Hey, guys.
I did a little oopsie and accidentally leaked the server.
But don't worry.
I changed the password.
It is now.
You guys are going to love the new password.
Member goons.
Yes, they're going to love the new password spread the word
if a dragon couldn't log in it's because i change the
password there you go the new password is i'm gonna also
like all right there you go let me edit the other stuff too
i need to edit like the original uh There you go.
New password.
There you go.
You guys like my new password, guys?
Yes.
No, no.
I did more than just add a number.
I did a lot more.
Yes.
For those who are like, for the non-member goons who are
like, what's the new password?
Guess you gotta be a member to find out what the new
password.
where it is whoa it's a huge change it really is yeah yeah I
am very good at cyber security I'm really good at it yeah
actually leak the server on the on the public stream for one
for like two seconds but don't worry don't worry i hope i
hope all you member goons feel so safe now with my top of
the line cyber security skills yeah i should be part of the
cyber police or something uh no leaks also don't keep
self-snitches leave a super chat thank you thank you
pampered new year new you no more leaks starting now yeah
now there's no more leaks guys 2026 is a great time for me
right now um anyway so i am a little worried about this game
not down it seemed like really slow today i just can anyone
like just give it to me straight like is steam downloads
really slow today or is it just me is it because like maybe
i don't know if it's the game maybe it's the game it could
just be the game because like i know i remember um yeah i
was like there's no way it could take i gave it like 15
minutes it's still at 1 because i know like some games take
like a really long time to download or update depending on
like um what the server is from um and basically like i
remember because every time in the in the past when we did
apex updates It would take like several hours some like at
one point an apex update could take like two to three hours
to fully update Even with fiber because the the server it's
drawing it from is like super slow You try restarting.
I think it might be the game itself.
I mean it's like I needed like an hour or some shit Okay, I
can pause and unpause.
Let me that would help I'm gonna try.
Oh, oh it went to two percent guys But like um, it's going
back down
Guys, it went to 2%.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
That's lucky.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait.
It went to 8%.
Okay, I think I had to pause and unpause.
Oh my god, that's all I had to do.
Guys, I just had to pause and unpause.
Okay, while I think we're good now, I think we're good.
I just, I just like, have you tried to be starting?
it and it for for once it actually worked all right story
time i talked about the story on members i was gonna like
say it here um so i don't know this person's watching but if
you are this is a little um this is a little wake-up call
for this person so for the last week remember goons know
this story because i already told the story uh but for the
last week i have been receiving um emails from this one
person that's been trying to like get in touch with this
fucking random vtuber who I've never met before, who I've
never communicated with before.
But apparently this vtuber follows me, but like I've never
like interacted with this vtuber before.
But anyway, I've been getting these emails and it's so
fucking weird.
And like this email is like, oh hey, thanks for inviting me
to your Christmas karaoke party I enjoyed your singing and
they're like anyway could you please let insert vtuber here
that would love to buy her lunch sometime and talk and then
they proceeded to give me their number and then their work
email and was like Merry Christmas and I was like what the
fuck and they also dox themselves to me like they gave all
their personal information to hoping that I will help pass
this down to this other VTuber who I've never like had any
sort of connection with before and and I thought that was
the end of the story and I was gonna tell this story earlier
because I thought it was the fucking weirdest email I like
ever like uh for uh this last month I thought last month
that was the weirdest fucking email I've got so far like
I've got a This is my weird email of the month.
But I forgot about it because a lot of other stuff was going
on.
So then I was like, all right, whatever.
I won't tell about this story.
It's just like a one-off thing.
And then the next week, the next week, I've been receiving
more and more emails from this random guy asking me to like
give, like asking me to pass his number.
to this VTuber because like I think I've received in total
um let me check in total one two three four emails from this
guy in the last week and each time he's like this is this is
the second email guy hey dokey can you tell insert VTuber
here to text me this is my number and then the third email
hey can you ask her to get a gym membership at this specific
insert gym name here because we're work out together and
then email number four he sent a video of himself
he sent a video of himself like i literally see the
thumbnail of this guy's face and i was like holy fuck i was
like full on face reveal um and assume i didn't click the
video by the way very close to I was so curious because I
really wanted to know like what is he gonna say but then I
asked I told my manager I was like what the fuck is up with
this guy and then and then like um and then my manager's
like don't click on it it's like don't you dare click on it
don't get like it can be a virus don't do it I was just like
oh but like I was like I'm pretty sure it's virus but he's
like yeah but like we have to be sick we don't know what
he's gonna do we don't we don't know what he has like what
he's capable of and then i was like but i really want to
click on it and then he and then my manager deleted all the
emails like he put it in the trash luckily even though it's
like he put in a trash i can still see the emails because
they did we didn't fully empty the trash can so i still have
the records of it for now until it's gone for the like
amount of days and it's gonna be fully white um so i was
just like i was just like what the fuck like i'm so tempted
to click on i really want to know what he said anyway some
of you were like blocked the emails but i was just curious
what he's gonna say next you know because like i wasn't the
main target for this guy i i was telling my members i was
pretty sure this guy has already been blocked by the vtuber
and like all her friends because like why the fuck is he
contacting me like why is he reaching out to me if like
someone who has zero association and doesn't even follow
insert vtuber here as like and i was like oh just because
i'm a vtuber i just happen to know all vtubers bro Bro,
that's like, he racist, man.
I was like, at that point, he's just shooting random shots
to see who actually knows it.
Like, like, maybe, oh, just because I'm a V-tuber, I just
happen to know this fucking random person that I've never
talked to before or even follow.
Damn, V-tuber profiling.
Stay away.
So anyway, I've had to publicly shame this guy.
Like, this is your wake-up call, bro.
This girl is most definitely not interested.
And most likely, have you blocked?
I have not had you blocked yet.
Because at that point, I just wanted to know what you're
going to say next.
But, bro, please, move on.
You have to move on.
most likely her and her entire like friend friend group has
blocked you if you are contacting me to try and get a hold
of her that means you've ran out of options to figure out
how to get a hold of her like oh yeah it actually downloaded
thank god so like i hope me and i don't know if you're
watching this but i hope me and the dragoons have given you
the wake up call and to realize that you gotta stop bro it
is very creepy like i am doing you a favor in publicly
calling you out right now because this is the only way it'll
get you the help you need to realize to stop doing this like
like please i leave her alone I don't even know who she is,
but like, if you are giving, and please do not give your
personal information to random virtual people, because bro,
I don't know, I could use your number and like fucking spoof
it.
I don't know.
Like, your parents were right about stranger danger.
What if I was
never put your personal information on the internet you have
a digital roadmap right now it's no longer a footprint like
you've like you've exposed your entire life to me by giving
me your fucking work email personal email first and last
name a video of you and also your phone number So please,
bro, I assume you did this.
You sent this email to a lot of people.
But, bro, please, you have to wake up.
She is not interested.
I have already enough on my plan, bro.
I cannot help you out because this is something that cannot
be helped.
You have to help yourself, bro.
Please, it's not too late.
up all right so anyway just wanted to talk about that like I
don't know if he's gonna send me another email the last
email I got was two days ago so um so we'll I'll give you an
update if I yeah I'm I'm doing you a solid right now so it's
been thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
If he does send another email, I'll give you guys another
update.
Because I don't know if he's still here.
Yeah, so anyway, I just wanted to talk about that.
I know some people are like, why are you enabling this?
Why are you like giving this guy attention?
This is the only way he will stop, guys.
This is actually like, if you don't call these people out,
they will not stop.
I know like this particularly is not even directed at me
like this is an intervention like I'm literally giving this
guy intervention right now because like I'm very like
unrelated to where the fuck he's like trying to get a hold
of and the fact that he's sending this random email to me
five different times on someone that doesn't even know who
the fuck he's talking to like I I'm just trying like this is
an intervention anyway anyway getting my spinach down
loading yay so as you guys might see from the title um it is
different from what the schedule is because um the reason
why is that i wanted to play the empress game but apparently
a lot of dragoons uh when i made the community post about
the empress game um people were saying um yeah imagine using
a real name on the internet absolute cringe i know jordan
wait is that also a photo of you right now let me look at
you
jordan jordan has salad you even have a oh wait your entire
your youtube videos are all pictures of you it's okay as
long as you don't have your personal number out there you're
fine jordan
It's okay.
At least you didn't dox your personal phone number at least.
You only did two out of four steps that the... I almost
doxed this guy out of the other guy's name.
Two out of the four steps that the other guy did.
Two out of four.
That's all right.
As long as not four out of four.
But yeah, so I wanted to do the Empress game, but a lot of
Dragoons and Community Post were telling me not to.
because apparently i think neemie did that did a stream of
the empress game and then she got struck down by youtube in
the middle of her stream because they thought that she was
watching a movie illegally even though it is a film motion
video game so it's basically like choose your own adventure
with like actors and stuff so they saw the game and thought
it she was watching a movie and her stream got taken down
halfway so like midway or some shit and she got like a
strike from it of that, I had to pivot to another film
motion video game.
So, you know, I took my gamble, you know, I was just like,
oh, she got struck down by playing a video game that looked
like a movie.
Let me play another video game that also is a movie video
game.
So, maybe it'll be different, but the title does have game
in it.
So, maybe because the title has game in it, a video game so
so maybe the maybe i'm i'm risking the gamba we're gonna
find out now um very yeah let's hope i win the 50 50 and
hope my stream stays up um so i'm gonna play the 50 50 and
hope that even though it is also a film motion video game
that i will still be able to to stream it
Gamba.
We always love the Gamba.
Alright, let's boot it up, guys.
I don't know.
Also, Sound guy alive today.
Any of the sound guys?
Alright.
So, oh yeah.
Context for this game.
It's basically a parody of Squid Game from what I was told.
And some of the acting is really, really bad.
So it could be...
So I was thinking, oh, it's like a bad movie.
Watch Align.
I feel like a lot of film-motion video games are like really
terrible acting in general because like all these actors are
like super underpaid and stuff i will not be surprised yeah
so it's actually a parody of squid games so there's actual
like squid games games in there where i think i was looking
at like i was reading the reviews and like i'm not i'll tell
you okay it's actually pretty funny literally one of the
parody games is called um let me see i need to find it it
was they were listing out the mini games and stuff And I was
like, what the fuck?
Oh yeah, it's called Sugar Art Challenge.
Draw intricate patterns with chocolate sauce.
So that's basically, that's like the, the longa.
What was it called?
The longa thing where you're poking the, the, the sugar
cookie.
But it's like, oh, you gotta draw patterns with chocolate
sauce.
I assume that's like, because it's the Joker's game.
But like squid, the squid.
Squid game.
All right, here we go.
So these are our fellow squids.
Sorry, the fellow jokers.
What is this?
I assume these are like achievements.
Clown.
Ooh.
All right.
Whoa.
Like, I know what you did last summer.
All right.
Oh.
What's happening?
That dream again.
Oh, that was a dream.
Oh, hey, pretty lady.
Honey, bad dream again.
Ain't so bad with you by my side.
Oh, shit, I got an item.
I shook my head, unwilling to mention that dream.
My belly button.
What's the story behind this?
Okay, that, yeah, the acting's pretty bad.
I'm like, what do you...
Now you ask me about the ring, how long have we been dating
for her?
Roll over and claim dominance.
What?
Oh my god.
Nice.
A lovely night.
It would tell us.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
Right off the bat.
I mean, the second option is ignore her.
I mean, God's gotta do what a God's gotta do.
I kissed.
Oh, that's it.
Nice.
Oh, that's all I did.
That's how I claimed diamonds.
I just...
I just kissed it.
Remember, kiss your ladies to claim to be the alpha.
Are you winning, son?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do we have our sound guy?
Is sound guy alive right now?
Is sound guy here?
If not, yeah.
All right.
All right, nice.
Let me know, sound guy.
Oh, nice.
Another kiss.
Two kisses?
Oh, my God.
I'm the top dog right now.
The top is...
my god what the oh okay we're at the club now yeah wait
that's my girlfriend why is she dancing for others my
girlfriend's a stripper oh i don't know if i like that
jack you promised that this game you designed would be a
success She should only be stripping for a man The strip
club should only have me as the customer I promise that I
can make it Kentucky's shaming it I am not shaming her I
just think She should only I should be the only patron In
this strip club I should buy up the entire strip club And
have her dance for me I
Hold down and slide.
Oh, am I giving her money?
Let's go.
Yeah!
I used to skip this part of the video.
Sorry.
You're super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
God, yeah, we're dead.
I just threw more of my income.
Nice quick time event.
Oh, is this before?
Before I...
Yeah!
mind lending me your nothing but petty rumor mind lending me
a bit more he's just like pay attention focus focus D wait
can I oh I can't I can't change the volume right now wait oh
my god is there guys we might have to replay this there's no
way to change the volume there's literally I'm stuck here
I'm gonna pick C.
Oh, wait, I can.
Oh, JK.
I have to, okay, here you go.
I have music and sound effects.
I could turn music.
Do you think the music is linked to the sound, to the
dialogue?
Wait, we'll test it here.
I want to see if the music is linked to it.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
It's not even that music.
Wait, I think sound effects is everything.
I have no money.
What is anything?
So what?
Nothing is connected.
Okay, sound guy.
I will tell you this.
I read the reviews and the number one complaint was that
this game has very bad audio balancing.
So good luck.
Honey, you're on your own.
Dude, a slider doesn't even work.
Wait, my best friend left.
Where's the boss?
Misses you.
Oh!
Why did he leave me?
Your damn sub, Jack.
Nobody else is going to.
I see the boss spinning the ring around his finger.
We should show him who his boss.
I'm kissing.
I think that's...
different type of game to game thank you the super chat
thank you thank you the ring is in gray with the conrad
family emblem damn you give me one more week that bastard
betrayed me how so oh wait what how did i die he knocked me
out and i actually got knocked out oh my god that's crazy
actually knocked me out for real it's so immersive all right
damn you yeah release me now I'm gonna show him I'm top dog
and he'll be like whoa whoa and they'll be threatened by me
release me you son of a bitch yeah oh oh he bitch slapped me
it didn't work guys what do you want me to do Well, well, if
you don't pay me by morning, you're going to be paying with
your life.
My life.
I guess I gotta spend it on the strip club then.
Nice high five.
I'll turn the music to Sony just in case.
All right.
I think that's sort of gameplay.
But we're not the gameplay yet.
Oh, hey, girl.
My girlfriend.
You need to leave.
Okay, they won't let you go.
They might make you disappear like the others.
Oh, I'm gonna be going to the Joker's game.
Wait for me.
Tomorrow we'll leave this place together.
Why tomorrow?
Why not today?
Oh, back home.
She had others?
Oh, shit.
The tomato juice.
Have I just been letting that slush around my mouth until
like...
uh what the is that they
couldn't did they not were they not able to find a real boy
to be like the baby version of me okay
turn on the tv i guess i'm a real boy
this morning william conrad the new face of the conrad
family gives campaign speech it's the first time the conrads
are going for president in 20 years ever since president
simon conrad was assassinated this speech could really
decide if the family makes that does not sound like a real
woman that does not sound like a real woman guys energy
sources and to supporting charitable initiatives we aim to
build a stronger and more So vote for me, William Conrad,
and I will take on the awesome responsibility that comes
with the president of this great nation.
What a hypocrite.
He acts all high and mighty, but he doesn't see us
struggling in the gutters.
Hey, at least we know, guys, we know that YouTube is not
going to strike us down.
Oh, hey.
Oh, the Joker, the Junkler.
There's no way they can strike me down.
for this type of game.
I downloaded porn before.
We don't like downloads.
To remove, drag the Joker icon.
I don't want to look at map.
Alright.
I did it.
What the heck is that?
How do I uninstall it?
Oh.
Hold left click and move to rotate the cube.
Click any to remove it.
Remove all the modules to start the game.
Okay.
Okay, we gotta remove the Junklers.
Oh, this is fucking easy.
I got this.
Um.
This is easy.
I got this.
Oh, God.
I'm confused.
Alright, we got some Junklers.
going in why are there so many junklers oh my god it's all
junklers they were just hiding
there you go bam i won the prize is 200 yeah that's stupid i
called bullshit i got 200 let's go easy money damn it's it's
true my jk bank my years of game design i can't help but
Nine years in game design?
I call bullshit on what this is.
Oh, more games.
Hold left click and move left to accelerate the progress
bar.
Then release in a target area to throw cards in that reach
the target score within the time limit to clear the stage.
What?
And then...
Oh, okay.
So I just have to hit the yellow and be...
There you go.
That should be fine.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
I went right Guys, I swear I know my left and right I swear
to God I know my left and right guys I know my left and
right I swear to God Left and right is so easy
Okay There we go Oh my god, the hardest phone app game of my
life.
I did it!
Yeah, it's a...
What a childish and poorly designed game.
Okay, sir, you have a failing company.
Sure enough, it's a trap.
There's no way...
If you can successfully complete the challenge, oh, one
billion?
Yes, please.
And one swig of beer from the table and everything goes
fuzzy.
Definitely bedtime now.
One billion Oh no, wait, I'm playing Pac-Man.
I'm playing legally distinct Pac-Man What?
Are you okay?
What happened?
There are demons!
Jack, remember?
You need to protect the art of the soul.
I always fight for Shreve.
The whale?
I got a, oh my god, the whale?
And then I hate, and then I was like, Gaming killed my dad,
so now I shall be a game designer.
For the whale's honor.
We have to finish this game for our gamer dad.
Oh my god, this is a fever dreamer.
now welcome gave
me kill my father okay all
right okay i know i'm sorry you're getting immersed but we
have to turn this uh sound guy says we need to turn this
down and then turn yeah i love bad games too i love i love
film film motion film motion video games because we get art
like this get beautiful beautiful work so all right all
right i did it i did sound good it's so bad it's good i know
did this person who made this game has something to do with
my father's death what's the conrad family involvement in
all this my god no jack's past i gotta know more about his
history now
oh because it's big oh because my ring is like like me like
it's a lying and then mine is uh uh well come with me della
come with me you want to live della
shot my girlfriend oh my god i want to hide the editor who
edited that special effect i wonder if it took him like i
wonder how long it took him to edit that special effect guys
it looked so real holy shit so dope the world of clouds.
Pennywise?
Okay, next chapter.
After being...
Wait, what happened to the guy that was chasing me?
You know, he had a gun!
And that's me, right here.
After being... He's the jonkler.
10 out of 10, CGI blood.
Jacob, thank you for the super chat.
This game is a fevered dream.
After being captured by a cloud and taken to an unfamiliar
area, your phone is gone.
replaced by a playing card and a new phone this is a game
but what exactly awaits me what happened to my girlfriend
and the mafia guy that was chasing me it feels like my eyes
are covered where am i
oh i told you i told you legally distinct squid game all
right of device that can't be taken off i don't know what
it's for how's the volume guys can you hear the dialogue my
phone is gone it's the jocular games obtain a phone that's
bullshit did i just get kidnapped by the designers of this
oh it's a little quiet i'll bring it up though i'm not clear
but it's not good news such a small card this is not a good
news the dialogue is quiet but everything else is loud oh
okay let me i'll boost it up just a little bit then all
right i loved octopus case papa they gave us super chat
thank you thank you for me since the number on my card is so
low use that map to get here too i see have a dot color on
oh no Very topical for today.
Oh, hey!
Yeah, thousand!
Yeah!
Hi, I'm Leon.
I'm a psychologist.
Oh, my God.
Leon, the psychologist?
The game designer.
First chat.
Yeah.
It looks that way.
It looks like it's for real.
See their faces when they sell that prize money?
They're already hooked.
but i don't think this is the first time that it's been done
you've seen this before it's the conrad family crest yeah
that's my family i'm conrad a look of surprise crosses
leon's face when he spots the conrad family emblem on my
clothes yeah i yeah i know i just got that from the way he
was telling me and the way he was acting it out like i don't
just like yes
me that this is a hug for sound god because holy what are
these sound settings also thank you for spending 10 on this
game dokey enjoy the watch you play this top-notch hollywood
game thank you with a super chat uv thank you thank you
thank you solid thank you with a super chat thank you thank
you no but if they have actors why do they need a green
screen phones and mirrors just use a video
I found it.
Yeah, I found it.
I don't know what's going to happen next, but it never hurts
to have somebody helping you out.
Oh.
Was he listening?
Who is he?
Oh, she cute.
Hey, folks.
Take this out.
It's a game of hearts.
Lucky me.
Guys, on my side.
In a game design standpoint, you must keep the cards
concealed.
In a game design standpoint, don't worry, everyone.
I'm a game designer.
It's like a video game, guys.
This is just like my video games.
Nice.
Jesus There are 52 Participants Please take care of your
belongings 52 Oh my god Guess I'm not making it past the
first round Good luck The game officially begins now Yeah
Where are the other 40 This is not looking like 52.
If you go out of bounds or run out of time, you'll be
eliminated.
Let's start the timer.
Alright.
Oh, got this.
We just gotta drop.
We just gotta paint the signs in chocolate.
How did you drop it?
Oh no, not the shock collar.
Oh no!
Oh my god.
Ashley kill people?
No!
No, that's a shock collar, not again!
I thought we were over this trauma!
How much longer are we gonna milk it for?
Could this be an off-the-grid criminal group?
How are they really tied to the conrad?
I need to find out what's happening in fast.
Oh my god!
AHHHHH!
Dialogue is 2026.
Get out of my head.
What
did she say?
Did any actual dialogue came out of her?
I think they forgot to turn her.
My God.
Have I even done the chocolate sauce yet?
bro how do you met no time to voice i better get moving now
but i'm gonna shock myself aren't i i've been just watching
i haven't even done this yet i've actually just been
watching
okay okay
oh guys it's too late guys this is not good this is a
Guys, I'm just trying to keep it tense, you know?
I just don't want to get shocked.
Okay.
I gotta make it close, you know?
I gotta make it more intense, because we're in the we're in
the Junkler's games right now.
Oh my god, I did it.
Oh my god!
We did it.
We made it fast.
and we got the other letters off screen
a win is a win like a pro I had to make it close cards from
the deceased for yourself within 60 seconds starting from
this round anyone with fewer than two cards will be
eliminated so I just need one more card what did she kept
like what the fuck
shit alive i must collect as many cards as i can what's up
what's up uh i'll go her close call i secured one card what
card is this uh him i secured another card oh my god am i
just gonna get all the cards for free nice tap to view the
info oh my god i secured two more cards i just get all the
cards for free marshal thank you for the super chat thank
you wow so what a close call guys the sound is so bad i was
maybe forgetting the camera's out of focus half the time at
least it makes it harder to see and hear the acting Bam!
Four cards!
What the fuck?
He took all my cards!
Oh,
oh, oh, oh, I got extra cards!
Take notice of a mate.
Oh, no, now I'm dead to him.
I made it through.
What's your name?
John.
What's yours?
Jack.
I got I got jacked to be honest.
I don't know how long I'm gonna last You seem like a nice
guy.
Oh, yeah, you'll have my back right?
Jacked I Don't know he seems he seems a suspicious guys He
seems I don't know He's like half British to and they always
make the villains the British guys
I don't know I trust him is it do I trust him or stay silent
or reject I played this games before he's clear yeah he
looks like the mastermind also I brought up the volume a
little bit more it's so obvious okay we have no okay of
course I got you I got you bro you already saved me
What if a fourth option kiss him?
Oh my god, he works for the bank.
I shouldn't have trusted him.
I knew it.
Obviously, anyone who comes here should be in need of money.
What brings you here?
Love, I guess you could say.
My partner is deep in charge with embezzlement.
And now the legal fees are in nightmare.
God knows I'm going to marry that idiot.
embezzlement you're gonna marry her she's gonna go to prison
those cards we collected from the start gotta matter
honestly my deck kind of sucks she can fix it nothing good
four of clubs and a nine of clubs i think he's talking to us
mike way too close i'm sure he's an honest man maybe i can
trust
in hand will now face emily's oh my god that actually jump
scared me i can't do this anymore can someone please please
tell me how we can't get out of here wait steal his cards
steal his cards 49 cards are in the hands of 13 of us i need
to figure out how the rules work as soon as possible i hate
this game hey you're gonna stick tough you coward suggest
that we keep you down it's very dangerous here so let's play
it safe bro that collar isn't even against his neck there's
no way he's getting shocked that collar isn't even like it's
so loose who put the collar on him i'm gonna i'm gonna punch
him i'm gonna do it yeah
yeah that's right and Smith have violated the rules and will
face penalties yeah I take you down with me yeah wait am I
dead oh okay whoops um okay let's let's rewind it's Rewind
time What do you do for a little game?
Don't think I can I can okay.
That's enough.
Mind your own business.
Don't go too far.
I won Same team Better watch your backs cuz I ain't gonna go
easy on you
Absolute cinema good good ending we were freed from our
prison The torture continues guys.
We gotta know what's gonna happen next in the Junkler games
guys I gotta know yeah we found a way out of here I heard
them call you Jack yeah he
just assumed she's dying he's
Ni hao Yeah, honey She's never spoken Chinese He just
randomly just went Ni hao Like
Just honestly assume she can't speak English In like America
My father dad is Chinese Hi, my name is Ling Xia Xia This is
my bestie Anna I don't know way let's wait until night when
the guards start to slack off at that time you might help us
find a way out of here aren't you here for the prize no
we're here to investigate anna's fiance who is missing and
used to be a part of this game all right she's definitely
dead it's dangerous here and we need a reliable guy to team
up with us and find a way out i'm reliable i literally told
you i'm a game designer bro No, but Lynn, we can't leave
right now.
I haven't found Jason.
Staying alive is what matters, town.
We'll do who Jason's been.
Ni hao.
You know Johnny?
I think that's my favorite dialogue.
I think I'll share.
I'll help you escape.
I think that's my favorite one so far.
Great.
we found the right guy hey go back in here bro these like
two one dollar mask that they i think they got like a marker
and drew like a joker on it we had jack john and jason
they're like uh chat gpt please generate names for me
starting with j related to the jocular games nightfalls and
your in a deadly game where nothing is certain the more you
know about others the better your chances of survival but
among these players who can you trust who is hiding
something and what other twisted rules are waiting to be
revealed i wish the sound balancing of this game is a bit
better because this game already is a 10 out of 10 for me
this game is a 10 out of 10.
It is amazing.
Are those Roche chocolates?
Or like, is that how you pronounce it?
The fucking nutty chocolate?
Just thinking about how I went through the corpse makes me
sick.
I already lost my appetite.
There's no way I can eat anything now.
Can we have the jazz piano?
Can we have the jazz music louder, please?
I could almost hear them talk.
What is this?
I got 100 grand?
Okay, I can actually leave now.
You
guys see that?
It's true.
I'm rich now.
All I do is win, win, win the matter what?
Got money on my mind and I can't ever get it.
There's a billion dollars on the line.
Wait, I think he's a parody of that rapper guy in the Squid
Games.
So you're a rapper.
Game designer
Yeah, he's like Thanos What's your name?
What's up with me to be the champion?
A beauty like you deserve to be protected by someone strong
Like me And what if you lose?
Why don't we discuss how we're gonna win later tonight?
You better watch yourself, Smith an eye on everything you
know how brutal they can be better hope we don't have a face
up kid because i'll send you straight to hell damn why
did you help me handsome oh
how's so
why you have my protection my queen this looks like yours
you've got nothing to worry about
Oh Oh, I can ask her more About your drug habit.
Why did you stop acting?
Sure.
I'm a big fan of your movies miss.
Oh, she's an actress What made you quit acting I was the
biggest star, you know But there just weren't enough, right?
Okay, it's very hard to tell she was an actress right now,
because that ain't she ain't selling it for me So the rumor
about Sophia's letter being a secret hunter is actually true
I think that he was a big shot That's crazy that they gave
her actress as like her job Because she was caught up in it
Alright, oh now I like Talk shit The drug thing?
That's just a rumor, right?
I wouldn't be here if they weren't true.
There's no point of hiding it.
But I promise you, I'll find my way back to the top.
Just sit tight and watch.
I wish the piano was even louder.
I can hear her, and I don't like that.
The music should be, like, at 300%.
Yeah.
Have you heard of the legendary hacker, Peter?
you mean the genius who won the global game design award
peter ages ago exactly you see he's my idol he was designing
this game and he said nobody could crack and then he
disappeared oh no way to be seen but i found this mysterious
code that he sent out i've deleted and it brought me to this
app i think peter's connected to this whole game oh you
don't look old enough he's a designer i'm 19 okay and plus
I've decoded many dark web secrets dark web secrets oh my
god she's a genius hacker oh plus I've got this a watch we
all got this it's not just a watch it's gonna help us find
bugs in this game yes please I'm pretty sure the other guys
can't hear us
the dark web
Surprises make people happy You should feel lucky to see a
great magician like me perform I feel so honest Your tricks
aren't that impressive How dare you?
She made the card disappear Maybe you should be performing
in a theater Not here Well, if my partner hadn't died I
wouldn't have ended up like this Listen, when I win the
grand prize I'm gonna rebuild my theater and I'm going to be
the greatest magician in history.
Kid, before you become the greatest magician in history,
better make sure you don't starve yourself in the next
round.
Okay, I got it.
I'm curious.
Okay.
Music, it's all a lie.
It's all...
The jazz does not stop.
Don't mess with her.
What the fuck?
We missed what the scene was missing.
And I asked around some more.
I could get some new leads this way.
The Jax will never stop.
Alright.
Let's see.
We'll talk to him.
I'm curious about his life.
Your age doesn't.
give you an advantage in a game like this you know on the
contrary it does i will miss this entire game for a
chocolate bar you're just a drifter to win it all in the end
you're gonna need some real skills what makes you think i
don't have any some guys catacombs and stomping at the point
you're sake dead dead the jazz make the sound balancing ties
everything together it makes it even better all right let's
talk to you here can you tell me more about jason's
disappearance before he disappeared jason by the way guys
this game is four hours long i have no idea how this game is
four hours I feel like I'm already at 50% of the gameplay
Four If he's still alive finding him might lead to some more
clues It could be like four hours for all the endings guys
maybe if we're lucky is just all the endings Maybe it's just
two hours I can't tell who is still I'm up.
No, you're gonna miss out.
Don't you want to know where Peter is?
You gotta stay and find out who Peter is.
Yeah, four hours for the true ending.
I can't quite tell what you do for a living.
Could you tell me?
Oh, a housewife is a job, though.
What's gonna happen to them?
I don't have to go.
I mean, wait, if you don't have a job and you're single, are
you trying to say you're a single mom?
Do you not have a dad?
Do you not have a husband?
Oh.
I'll stop the volume a bit.
Oh, so she wants the money to get out of the abusive
relationship.
At any cost, huh?
I saw you trying to pocket that fork earlier.
oh she stole the fork for money all right two more two more
people to talk to you
hi y'all do you look really young how'd you i just became an
adult the coming of age ritual in our village was horrible i
was hoping to earn enough money to escape an arranged
marriage that my father But it's even worse here if I had
had a known that accepting the out invite would have led me
here I never would have done it.
Oh my god, girl.
You're in a cup You'll protect me, right?
Sure, I'll protect all the women.
Maybe assuming I'm not dead
You're kind of skinny
It's the credit of my family
I was hoping if I could make enough money
Boy, you're just fucking skinny, girl.
You think I'm in, guys?
Guys, you think she liked that compliment?
You know, that technique where you compliment a girl, you
insult her and then compliment her later?
I'm just a mechanic.
Gotta stay in shape for the job.
by how sharp he is in the game there's definitely more to
him than just being a mechanic your necklace looks unique
yeah i'm just nagging her guys it's it works guys ain't
nothing serious looks like a signature piece for the
mercenaries oh how did he get over here so you're here for
the prize money too yeah my daughter susan is sick and we
need a lot of money to help her at least and yeah there's
absolutely nothing that i want to do to get back to her
okay nice okay so now we know all their life stories where
are we all we can continue now i need to use the washroom i
hope the actors get free it is it's the chocolate It is!
They got the Roshan chocolates!
Hold down and slide.
Oh, I follow her.
Quick time event.
I recognize those chocolates anywhere.
There's two bros being next to each other.
Would you like to...
Can psychologists really read my...
My...
Bro, how fucking stupid am I?
I think all psychologists are fucking got telepathy.
Alright, we gotta team up with me.
Want to team up for the next rounds?
Depends on what information you can offer me.
If you have knowledge on the game or the other players...
They need to bump fists at the urinal.
They give you a few tips.
But I don't make friends so easily.
Oh.
Trust is dangerous in this game.
How do you know?
So what brings you here?
Psychology pays well.
Why risk your life for extra money at a place like this?
For love?
What all went sideways?
Sideways.
Huh?
She never told me that she was a mom boss as well.
Wow.
You also dated a stripper too like me?
Same z's.
Can psychologists really read my mind?
So can psychologists really read minds?
Not exactly.
But I can tell who will be a good friend, and who will be a
future enemy.
Where do I fall?
Yeah, where do I, where am I at?
I think it would be best to not become my enemy.
I've done a lot of work for the Conrad family, after all.
Sounds like he knows something valuable.
Hope he doesn't bite the dust, too.
soon.
Ooh.
I could consider an alliance and give you more intel, but I
need to know more about the Conrad family.
You're no friend of the Conrad's, that much is clear.
Best advice I could give you is to stay out of it.
Move their fingers in every pie in this country.
Play with fire, you get burned.
Ever thought maybe they put you here on purpose yeah i mean
you slept with the boss's wife they can't just let that
slide to them i'm nothing even if i did get out there's no
guarantee that i'd escape yeah let's just get him again
they'll put you in the next game the next jungler game i
might as well take my chances here otherwise i could just
vanish like the others end up dead without anyone ever
knowing what happened You said you worked with the Conrad
family Who specifically Well, I even know Like who that
person is I'm like, who?
Mr. Future President himself Oh, the guy that was on the TV
Okay, yeah, be that good I'm a psychologist, yeah Like, bro,
you're a fucking psychologist What the fuck do you mean?
I don't stay here too long
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Joki, you're so amazing at FPS, but you're totally
birdbrain.
Also, you're an amazing support player.
Did I do it right?
How did you get locked through the door?
How did she, oh my gosh, how did you walk through the door?
I'm going to be here if I was.
You're up to something more.
I can feel it.
So you're not just here to help your friend and her fianc,
are you?
right i'm with interpol holy shit interpol also my friend on
i need to know what's going on over here gotta plan things
carefully if i figure out who's behind all this hold up
she's in a men's bathroom that's illegal whoa she's on the
international police people's eye don't lie i can tell
you're not just here for the money you've got a sharp eye
continue i heard leo mentioned something about the missing
people i think that's something to do with the conrad family
and you you seem to care a lot about them what's your deal
with them well since you're looking into them too
wait are you one of the terrorists what there's terrorists
now what I was digging into missing cases And went through
files 20 years ago The terrorists who killed the Comrade
family's last hair All had this
That's my dad My dad was an assassin Oh my god I'm following
in his footsteps Oh they're like I heard a girl was in the
men's bathroom Ha ha
the shamu assassination
um i'm pooping um hello
interval is a bunch of data analysis they don't send people
on the field ah marshal thank you for the super chat Thank
you.
Thank you.
Um, that's not what death note taught me.
Um, I remember the interpol police Um, oh man, she actually
looks like that death note interpol police character before
she died and got a heart attack Get your mind out of the
gutter Get your mind out of the gutter
Yeah, what do you do at the bank?
So what exactly do you do at the bank, John?
Just a small time credit officer really my job pretty boring
most days i can watch a few youtube videos and whatnot but
if it wasn't for what happened with my partner i wouldn't
risk coming here we should just break up with her she
embezzled it's not like a tea oopsie tani mistake like
that's jail counted the players in the suits besides the
three discards i'd say every player has like three to five
cards getting more is gonna be pretty difficult he's indeed
a financial guy sharp with numbers could be a valuable asset
John watches Doki Bird, let's go.
Why do you trust me so much?
Oh man, the Jazz is back, guys.
We never leave Jazz.
I've gathered most of the details now, but I still don't
know how many cards each player is holding.
It says I can't escape right now.
I need a plan ahead for the upcoming matches.
Looks like I could use a helping hand with this.
Out of everyone here, I've identified three potential
allies.
trick could come in handy for this game a psychologist could
help me read everyone's thoughts and moods like what does he
i i don't think jack knows what a psychologist actually does
like i when you're at when you're getting therapy they ask
you how do you feel right now like they don't they don't
actually know how to read your mind like a profile they
could have spot the details i've Miss.
Guys, I think we're fucking stupid.
It's psychologist their psyche, right?
Now, which one should I pick?
Guys, I should pick the psychologist, guys.
He can read minds.
Okay, where the fuck did the magician come from?
Where why why do i have mr lucas here okay i gotta pee i
have too many questions i will most like i would i pick anna
or leon i'll let you guys decide i'm gonna but we're not
picking the magician
guys i swear we are not picking magic mat i i don't know
we'll make it i Gordon Anni Nexie Bite Space Papa Medi
Forward Solid Alan Thank you For the super chat Thank you
Alright Okay I'll do a I'll do a poll Okay Who Anna Mind
reader Magic Man Magic Man all right we'll do a poll we'll
figure this out i swear to god i swear to fucking god guys
you know what we're picking
you know the answer so cute you know what the people want
fine i'll change the it's not okay okay fine it magic man
you're a skilled magician i think you're my best bet in this
game i mean finding a partner for this game is definitely
the right move but you know magicians are pretty picky about
their partners magicians are really careful huh well ever
since i was learning magic my dad always said a magician
needs to be quick on their feet i can't uh have a partner
She doesn't even want me.
Can't finish the game quickly.
Maybe we should just forget about it.
Bro, she rejected us.
Oh, wait, okay, we got...
Okay, we're playing matching tiles.
Okay, we're playing a little game.
Okay, now complete the remaining tiles.
Cap, what?
Oh, it's just...
Okay, that's fine.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I can do this.
Okay, it's just be jeweled.
Wait, what?
Okay, there you go.
It's shittier, bejeweled.
All right.
All right, there you go.
See, this is easy.
What?
How is this a game?
I'm so confused.
All right, here you go.
It's barely bejeweled.
It's not even bejeweled.
I'm just playing.
I'm just matching shit.
up uh that should be everything okay nine three a uh a uh
sevens tens uh oh i oh my god are you oh okay okay how like
i could not move this Are you serious?
Okay.
Okay, I figured it out.
Alright, never mind.
It is a little bit more complicated than I expected.
Bum.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
How?
Are you kidding me?
I can just move it.
Oh my.
Oh my god, it won't move.
How do you want me to move this?
Okay.
Okay, this changes everything.
Actually, wait, this...
What?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you... Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Alright.
Can I move that?
Okay.
Can't move that.
I got this out of the way.
I just gotta match it.
It's just gotta connect.
But some of them you can move the entire fucking block.
Like this.
Like how come somebody can move the entire goddamn block and
then others I can't.
Like this.
I gotta get rid of the 10 here.
5.
Okay.
Like...
Oh, we can get rid of the 9 at least.
And then the 8.
And then the 4.
And then the 2.
And then...
The queen.
God, out!
Okay, it's fine.
How do I get out of this?
Am I...
Stuck?
Oh, I can move the 10.
Okay.
I can move the 10.
That's good.
You can move the heart.
And then the 5.
7.
9.
Okay, there we go.
Sometimes I can move.
Sometimes I can.
Here's the scoop.
John has three cards.
His highest one is the queen of hearts.
How do you know?
I'm a magician.
David will leave it.
A magician never tells her secrets.
If he's telling the truth, then John isn't as genuine as I
can.
Oh,
oh, they can be all my friends.
Okay.
Oh, they'll just give okay.
Choices don't matter.
Okay, let's go You have a point, but how can I be sure
you're the right partner for this?
So you're looking to put me to the test.
I'm playing around I'd be like I'll be your partner Who are
there is never free will in the jocular game It is usually
at this precise moment that I can say if someone is
trustworthy or not
So Jack How long will it take you to crack this puzzle?
Oh My god, let's do a puzzle guys
All right, that's fine this is not together it's literally
okay we do corners first it's okay i have 14 minutes to do
this puzzle where the fuck are the corner pieces all right
we gotta find the corner pieces guys where is it okay
there's that corner all right okay that that should be like
see okay I swear to God is I just there all right the other
corner all right there you go god I'm so good at puzzles
guys surely that's gonna go somewhere all right and then is
this one um another corner it's like here I had a feeling.
It's either here or here.
There you go.
That's the nose.
I could tell.
I'm just going off vibes right now.
Is that the picture of the Johncler?
Oh my god, it's him.
It's John Johncler.
It's gonna get me before I can save Shammu.
Okay, that's the last corner.
That should be here.
Okay, now I can just speedrun all the rest.
It's like here.
Wait, I can skip the puzzle.
Don't even have to do it.
It's just the illusion of choice.
I can't believe it.
They're lucky I like doing puzzles.
I used to do puzzles all the time at my grandparents'
palace.
It's right here.
It's Skipper.
Actually skip up.
Oh.
Tabbed up.
There you go.
And done.
I was.
What does that mean?
Oh.
Alright.
I don't even know what...
What is that intel?
Honestly, I've always felt a bit uneasy around
psychologists.
But it's skip, but I solved it.
I don't read your mind.
Not at all.
I'm pretty open about myself.
It's not a big deal if you see through me.
But me, me, me, me, me, me.
But, me, me, me, me, me, me, I'm a good choice.
But I do have some expectations for my friends.
Oh, like what?
Mm-hmm.
Psychologists can interpret anybody's thoughts based on
their actions.
Huh?
Remember that candy drawing game you play?
played earlier yeah
he's like round two oh my what the fuck okay that's not a
two
oh my god okay that is not a cute
all right
Here we go.
Alright, where do we go now?
Oh my god, this is like the longest.
The longest trip.
Alright, here we go.
We did it.
Oh, we did it.
Based on my understanding of human behavior, I can give you
a little tip.
Be careful, Vanna.
Huh?
And Ada.
Why?
that's it why but she works at interpol no oh my god look i
like how they took off the sticker they took off the sticker
because they're not legally allowed
oh what was the chocolate drug oh no never mind they just
took us to the ferrero chocolates my legally distinct
chocolates Game of the...
I know, right?
Oh.
Hey, this looks like a servant scammer.
Separate scam.
What are you doing?
I'm stuck on my last bit of code that Peter sent over.
I just can't seem to understand it.
Plus, the signal's bad, so a lot of my device functions are
down.
Yeah, let's talk louder in front of the guards.
Relic?
Relic.
Is it referring to the organizer of this game?
This could be a key clue.
I need to give it some thought.
Am I thinking right now?
Like, why did...
Oh, okay, after John...
I was like, alright.
Silence.
I am going to think now.
I head back to my bunk.
Thinking about...
To what I heard at the restaurant.
What's Rick hiding?
I'll go talk to him.
I got a feeling you're not just anybody.
wasn't nominated but claire 33 was on you and they taught me
plenty exactly that's why i'm hoping we can team up it looks
like nice wig like 10 years later you know what and sounds
like how way he sounds like it too doesn't sound like a fond
memory hey listen i need a partner he's not just bluffing oh
my god this is that's nice wig of course there yeah you
remember card toss well how many cards do you think you can
throw into this hat this time oh my god not again no no it's
okay i know how to drag i know what she's left now
okay oh god it's fine i know where left and right is i could
speed run this watch see
on me there you go rick was amazed by my car throwing tricks
he taught me how to cheat at cards this trick could be
useful later in the game the red light of the surveillance
camera is on constantly and the door is unlocked i'm gaming
if i try to make a move the surveillance camera yeah this
was released like a week ago guys
Let me cook This decision Leave Just go out
Surely it's not a Trap, right?
You can just do that Just leave What could go wrong?
Yeah all right whoa couldn't catch me yeah we're metal
gearing right now is this metal gear solid whoa god i'm so
good at quick time
whoa boom
oh wait okay smash the key I had to learn how to turn a
doorknob guys a doorknob quick time event oh my god is this
another hide don't worry I've mastered the art of going left
and right
telltale is finished yeah they're so quiet now after this
game got released
whoa I'm jingle peaking right now Bam!
Right side!
Oh my god, he's so confused.
They have to hire better guards.
If they are throwing out $1 billion left and right, I feel
like they might need to retrain their security team.
This is why they gave this.
What the fuck?
Oh, did I make it?
Oh, I made it.
Okay, that was...
The timer was so fast.
I don't know if you guys saw that.
That timer was crazy.
Jesus Christ Scared the hell out of me Oh my gosh, she
scared me I can't believe you actually came Yeah I don't
want you getting hurt Just be careful, okay John's asking
But I arrived I said suddenly checking out the place to see
how far I could wonder And I warned And warned them to stay
inside because guys are patrolling everywhere outside.
Guys, we're so in.
I'm definitely saving the actress.
How am I supposed to find out if Jason's even here then?
Oh, my God.
My fianc, who I love very much.
You want to go out there and search for someone?
Don't tell me.
You're going to go ask the diamond-shaped cards where he is.
Are you?
Maybe we should focus on getting through to the next round.
The two of us might be enough.
Me and...
Babe.
Don't underestimate a pretty woman.
I might just be your best partner here.
Because she called me babe, though.
She called me babe.
Oh my god.
Oh, God.
We're in a closet together.
We're so in.
Oh, and she's locking the door.
I can tell you're a strong man.
Oh, me?
Since you're willing to look out for me.
Yeah?
It's only fair if I give you something in return.
A kiss?
Oh my god, as for the rest Come once you get me out of here
Oh
Wait, that's it Jack, John says you're a game designer Any
chance you can get me out of here I don't want to die in
here I can't help you right now But I hope you can make it I
don't Bro, why are they putting so much faith in the game
designer Jack God bless we literally have an inner pull
officer here and she's like but you're a game designer yeah
I'll just be a game designer help guys you think I made the
poor choice of picking the actress instead of the
psychologist two cars in hand so they're out what they
someone they got your cards stolen oh well I was I was
hooking up I got two cards see I've got them right here I
have two cards magic
man magic man it's him we were all in our beds except him
and he's standing right there Jack Is that true?
No.
I just got back from next door and they died.
Look, I'm sure it wasn't Jack.
Maybe it was someone else.
Let's search him and find out.
No one's laying a hand on him.
Or you'll have to deal with me.
That's right, she's from Interpol.
Rick was sleeping right next to Lucas.
Jack, are you sure you didn't see anything when you came in?
It was dark here.
I couldn't see a thing.
kids there's no time to argue whoever stole the cards
they're also gonna have extra badges we should all have the
same amount of badges how about we put them out in the open
and whoever has the most I mean I could just not put out my
badges yeah but yeah they don't know yeah it's hiding their
exactly that's not foolproof badge count won't decide who
lives or die in the next round it matter who stole them
either way i'm not sleeping tonight thanks wig
you look a little bit nervous are you the seat smithman
lucas probably have some useful items on them no guards have
come for the body a search while they're distracted yeah
that's not gonna make me suspicious at all let me snatch
something quick before anyone notice might need it down the
road.
Alright, let me go steal something real quick while they're
fucking arguing on who sold the cards.
Yeah.
Oh, girl.
Okay, what does she have?
Yoink.
My cards now.
The magic temperature card found in Lucas might come in
handy.
Free loot.
Oh, I grabbed from him his fucking belt.
It's like a nice switchblade.
Bro, this guy's...
Yeah, okay.
Okay, I don't think you're having to fucking switchblade.
Okay, I'm just out of the shank of motherfucker.
What is it?
Oh, it's gum.
And found on Smith seems pretty.
How do they not see?
Like, this is in front of them.
I did not see it.
Nobody can see me.
Got some gum.
The only door lock in this place is the closet.
What do they mean by the closet is a very dangerous place,
okay?
You must be working together.
And you're gang you up on me because I'm alone.
Marshal, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
I'm not gonna argue.
Besides, I prefer arguing.
I am the master.
Whoa.
I am the master thief.
Oh, goodbye.
He's like, he's pretty heavy, guys.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, where's the eye holes?
Wait, wait, wait!
I said
this is like a fucking penis nose.
Why does it look like that?
What?
Shabu by...
The whale from Ocean Park?
From Seaworthand?
Yeah, we're always in our hearts.
Oh, no.
I'll remember a kingdom of Shamu and that I'm always a
warrior of Shamu.
Oh my god!
I love Seawood!
Shamu, our god.
Free Willy.
I will free all the whales, daddy.
I will free all the whales.
Every single one of them.
Moo!
There are demons!
Jack and my mother.
You must protect the honor of the soul and always fight for
each other.
Get lost!
This is my territory though, brat!
What?
Where did he come from?
Who is this random kid?
What?
Grants everywhere.
I didn't get it.
very far what else do you want to know what did I get pulled
like a random surprise bully aside from being a bit anxious
I have lots of travel from different scenarios
she smells good
oh my god
jack bro what about the actress oh but
isn't your time for daydreaming right now oh my god fuck
that fuck this game is so good this game you're beautiful
touch your face oh my god okay touching your face might be
bad i'll just say you're beautiful this is why you this is
why you need job bro needs multiple therapies and guys thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you Thank you for the
super chat, thank you, thank you.
Shame.
You're beautiful.
You're so beautiful.
I think touching her face would be a lot worse.
Hope we can stick together.
Guys, I'm in.
Oh my god.
I had her at Nihao.
You said you read the files on Edward Conrad's
assassination.
Did you happen to see the name?
You're in part two.
Do you know about this case?
I do see the wife number two What's your deal with him?
Find out the truth And I'll tell you everything Then you
better hang in there I think we'll make a great team Yay The
mysterious game just keep piling up So many Do Ling and I
have a chance to learn more secrets Lost in thought I
drifted into deep sleep Trying to look forward to tomorrow's
match A wonderful day has begun.
Good luck, everyone.
The game grows deadlier by the minute.
The remote in your hand holds power over life and death.
Yours and someone else's.
But in this twisted contest, where anyone really traded
away, and when does the nightmare finally end?
Did he hit the lap these two thoughts?
Welcome to the Joker Museum.
Please follow our hints and discover clues to our opinion.
Find a little control that matches the code on your hand.
And confirm our stop on Discord.
If the clock runs out, you'll be eliminated.
The desktop game begins now.
Please enjoy exploring your toys in the last hour.
Okay.
What fucking game is this?
I know the writing is so good, guys.
Okay.
all right there's
a camera on the screen looks like it's gonna take some time
to figure out honestly this out this game it's too bad they
released a game in December if they just waited one more
week Jesus how is he so close to the mic now Jack I'm here
first you guys best be looking somewhere else we were here
first obviously if this if they waited one more week it
could have been a contender for best indie game time waits
for no one so I suggest you don't waste your time on me and
hurry and look somewhere else why do you have to mess with
us this place is huge don't think you're gonna survive in
this game by tagging along with him what's wrong with me how
powerful someone is in this game the bigger the target they
become I'm a game designer!
Me?
I'm a game designer!
Let's just move to the side and check things out.
Why did you hate me?
But she's such a Karen.
I think she just doesn't trust me.
All right.
Look at all these creepy fucking dolls.
Wait a minute.
Looks a bit unusual.
Why?
They all look unusual.
Jesus Christ.
This doll's fucking spooky.
It's because I didn't pick her.
Oh!
Rotate the modules to adjust the circuit, directing the
current from the power.
When all paths within all terminals are connected to the
current, when selected and not, it will appear in red.
Rotate the modules to continue to adjust directing.
Okay.
There you go.
Yay!
Okay, that was easy.
Alright, so I just have to do all of them.
A very ordinarily cloth door doesn't seem to be related to
the remote control.
Okay, so this one's normal.
Alright.
She's a normal, duh.
He's like, okay.
gotta make sure okay no okay although i would say this doll
is freaking freaky as hell this doll has her hand in a box
so there must be something there
okay never mind it was that doll the freaking freaky ass
doll over there oh i can continue right now oh i already
found it i figured it out in the first try never mind i
don't know whose it is but it's a solid start it's just that
box Found a key.
I don't know which room it's for, though.
Why not try the room next door?
I cooked a little too hard.
I thought too hard for that.
These Makus, you gonna take them from you?
A locked door?
I don't want to step on your toes or anything.
But before you go all Hulk mode on that door, why don't you
give the key a shot first?
Oh my god, we're working together!
Guys, we're gonna split the billion dollars.
what he gave you the key and now you're not gonna let us in
all right i'll let y'all in but just make sure that if y'all
find anything in here you don't even think about stashing
the way why are you still using your brain because it's a
mystery also he has to lock let me in anyway There was no
way he could, like, lock me in.
They found that they're actually headlamps and found...
Oh, is that how it does the shock?
They just turned the headlamps on and off?
Wait, how much is it, Vaisal?
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, what's the heart?
I assume it's the bottom, right?
Because that's the fucking module shit.
They cost 13 euros.
That's a little too expensive for how much I thought it was
going to be for like the budget of this production.
Seems useless.
This is the only thing that looked useful in the entire
selection.
There's no way.
These are just...
That's just water and food coloring.
Oh my god, I'm going to drink it.
Okay, I was going to say.
Don't be stupid.
chemistry or did they just made this shit up oh my god it's
the fucking okay uh oh is this oh my god it's so it's the
stupid tick tock videos where you're trying to match it
together oh my god is the is the actual is the fucking oh my
god I don't know if you guys the fucking video of the where
you have to like match it up that's those uh we'll do orange
oh oh my god i thought okay i'm okay um um i might have
messed up
this is bad just realized this is a little oh shit oh shit
okay I messed up a little um oh fuck okay oh I might need a
oh my god I might need a restart okay let me think guys I
can I can cook this oh my god okay blue here blue here um
okay green here uh orange here okay I'll put the red here oh
fuck I should have okay they're all orange okay that's good
okay and then purple here and then I don't have yellow
Oh, no.
Give me a sec.
I'm thinking.
Can I use the empty vials?
Oh, I can.
Okay, I can.
Okay, I can use the empty vials.
Okay, this is fine.
I can actually use the empty vials.
Okay, there you go.
Okay, and then yellow.
And then...
for this and uh okay we're going to grab the purple from
here and grab the purple here and then the yellow here okay
we're cooking now now we're doing i'm braining i'm braining
it is that three okay yeah that's three okay and then orange
oh fuck okay we gotta grab get rid of this We need that
blue.
Okay, wait.
And then this here.
And then red for this.
Okay, and then...
I'll grab the blue, though.
Blue for here.
And then we gotta pour this here.
Pour another orange here.
Pour another blue here.
And then...
Bam!
We did it!
We're so smart.
We collected the key information.
The clue in Daniel's hands points this room full of jars.
No doubt about it.
This room where control belongs to Daniel.
If he makes it to the end?
Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Those are the headlaps.
What do y'all have?
Pretend not to have found anything.
That guy was mean to me.
you saw it did you find my remote no not really i i didn't
find anything i'm warning you give me my remote oh no
otherwise let's go you guys don't want to see oh
we definitely can't be friends what y'all better watch your
back but friendship is magic what So the picture on the
phone shows the key's location Oh, okay, we're just gonna
ignore that he fucking punched me We will save time if we
search separately Please let me know Wait, but he punched
me.
He said fighting is not allowed.
What the fuck?
Hey, that guy punched me.
Oh, yeah rules for Z, but not for me
oh it's not allowed in it's allowed in the games okay i see
what's this
there's nothing here it seems my remote control was already
taken i should ask them did you find yours no my clue is a
carving knife oh wait i'm just lying to everyone did you
find anything nope not anything here yet there was something
on the uh the shelf outside what number are you seven and
yours what george found isn't yours better wait until you
find yours before we talk they're just trying to pit us
against each other for this game we'll be much safer if we
can be honest and help each other we have to work together
why whether i find yours or you find mine what what his
number is we can all return them to each other right away
I'll even tell you that I found a remote control but I need
to confirm your numbers first don't tell him anything guys
what he's tricking us into something why don't they trust me
now I thought they believe in you Jack yeah you should
believe in me no you're in luck looks like he won the bet um
i'll uh she's sick i'll trade you this number one for that
number 10.
there's no need she's sick it's all up to you whether you
give back and uh there's no need it's all up to you whether
you give it back to the original owner or not that's none of
my business what are the odds jack you really are great we
are you son of a bitch i promise if i see meant to be guess
i'll have to look elsewhere it was destiny oh my god you are
a bunch of chakases what do you mean we're helping each
other what happened to her she's just stressed out too much
it's about time we all need to hurry oh my god we're a match
made in heaven That's gonna be crazy.
She's six and I'm seven.
Oh,
there's no head.
Oh, there's no purpose.
And I just thought I connected to something.
No head?
Oh, it is.
Oh, maybe there's a box behind it.
All right.
Oh, my God, it's this.
them.
Click empty screws to place use the initial empty holes to
dismantle all victory's cheat when all planks disappear.
Okay.
Um.
There you go.
Oh!
I see.
Okay.
Oh, that's easy.
Wait, I can just speed run this.
There you go.
Now I put that here.
And then that's gone.
Oh, yeah.
This is so easy.
This is a puzzle.
for babies.
Watch that.
Oh.
Then put that here.
And then
boom.
Boom.
I fixed it.
Yeah!
A baby puzzle for a baby doll.
Where the fuck did that tank come from?
Okay.
all right i opened it three guys i did it i opened it as i
tucked away the remote control numbers i turned it around
angry shouts erupt from the nearby music box room guess i
better check it out all right give it to me we're all gonna
die men ain't shit i just said they have eight is one
they're totally lying they only said that because they saw
you had one
but don't listen to that nonsense That makes sense.
Ada, if you've really got mine, then you must know my
number, right?
Rick, I'm guessing you want your number four, right?
Oh, come on, you have to know Rick's totally playing you.
He just wants me to get back his number four remote control,
and he's trying to block you from giving me back my number
11.
Alita, is this what you're looking for?
Eight is mine.
Rick, she wasn't lying at all.
Oh, damn, he's a stupid girl.
He just tipped your hand.
We're done for it.
Why don't we all just give each other the remote?
Oh, because the more people that died and more money to get
right where.
Then we'll perish together.
Hey, Jack, you don't want the number 911, do you?
Sorry, before I rolled in here, I already had a clue about
someone's number.
and from what I heard I'm guessing this number three remote
control in my hand might actually be yours.
Am I right, Sophia?
Oh, darling.
Oh, yeah!
Chill.
We need to sort this out.
Nice week is evil?
You know how she left 100 thieves today?
He went and joined the jocular games.
That's his big announcement.
But you and Lolita need to hand in Ada's and mine first and
then we could chill darling Jack don't listen you got
Sophie's number three remote on you right there right yeah
just let them switch first and then we'll give Ada's hers
remote back and then you can give Sophie hers that's the
fair way Jack okay I don't like him or her they've been
trying to call me they're not gonna make it very far in this
game damn isn't gonna do you any favors this is a game of
survival but she's a movie star and she's pretty
hey da wait she's ada right wait which one's ada what's the
movie i i forgot her name i just know she's the movie star
is the karen the ada is karen ada
Okay, I'm listening to Rick.
I'm listening to Rick.
I'm not listening to the Karen.
Nah, she was a bitch.
She said I was stealing.
What the heck are you doing?
Well, don't forget.
This is a game of I die, you die.
You gave me a kiss.
I've got a better shot.
Jack.
You're right now.
My guess is right.
That destroyed number nine remote control should be honest.
Sophia.
You bitch!
My wives are fighting!
Whoa.
Oh, sorry.
Chill out.
It's almost time.
This is no time to fight.
Did you find a remote control?
Nope.
Had enough of this silly game.
Just disgusting to be here.
Ladies, ladies, please!
Calm down, ladies!
Oh no!
In the puppy room earlier.
Awesome!
Oh yay!
You gotta do what it takes to stay alive.
Check this out.
Linda, he's got your number six.
Oh!
Before we swap, just a heads up.
Don't be fooled by his appearance.
The Jack you think you know is how he wants you to see him.
What?
Huh?
You can't ignore anybody in this game.
You might be peaceful now, but you could easily be enemies
in the next round.
Why don't you take him out now?
Wait, no!
Wait, she said she wants to hang out after!
Come on, Lynn.
Lynn.
Jack could easily be more trustworthy than Leon.
Bro, that guy's a psychologist, bro.
You can't trust him.
Tough cookie.
Six, seven,
six, six, six, six, seven, six,
seven, six, seven, we did it, guys.
Emergency alert.
The ace of hearts has been murdered and the murderer is
among you.
The result of this round of the death clock game is in
battle.
This is the girl's number four.
Was Dengon Rompadel?
Wait, how did he get murdered?
Excuse what?
Wait, how did he die?
How the fuck did he kill him?
We have nothing.
Did he leave something behind?
Oh, you left the glove.
Okay, I got the memory.
i'll grab the fucking sd the sd card real quick he died from
cringe he read the script
all right
he saw too much where have you been why are you just showing
up right now yeah you can kill him did you i've been in the
security room my clue is the camera what's going on here
isn't it obvious someone killed the guard with a carving
knife a carving knife where the fuck was the knife jack
isn't your clue the carving knife it can't be jack he was
with me the whole time wait she had my number in a box
flying with the remote control Anna and I grabbed it and we
left the room right Anna oh wait she's still alive let's go
to the security room how is Anna still alive
We kill the guard.
You can we just do that?
If someone's about to die, we'll just kill the guard.
Oh, nice.
I love my loopholes, yeah.
Yeah, because he was like, the round is invalid because a
guard is dead.
I know this is on a Mac.
Does he just start shanking him?
Oh, he's like, uh, like this, uh, Royal Guards!
The British Royal Guards.
Oh, whose shoes is that?
Whose feet is that?
Oh?
Why is he turning the camera?
Don't those eyes look familiar, would you hear?
Oh, that's Beyonce?
Jason!
No way.
Do you think Jason has been killed?
Oh!
So, who do you think killed him?
Honestly, I'm clueless.
Who do you think it could be?
Well, I mean, we saw the shoes and pants.
There's two guys on the screen.
One is George.
And the other is like a little dude that's following him.
It must be one of them.
Yeah, I know.
Just from the fucking ass.
You can tell you that.
How does the rat...
George was asleep the whole time.
It couldn't be him.
How does she recognize Jason?
Telling the truth.
You could be working together.
Mm-hmm.
And the person behind you is clearly not Lynn.
Shut the fuck up, okay?
Anna was the one behind me, and after I left, I have no idea
what she got up to.
But she does look pretty suspicious.
Wait, are you saying that Anna is the murderer?
No way.
There's no way!
That's her fianc!
She couldn't have been killed.
Jason, right?
Jason who's Jason what are you guys hiding it's none of your
business okay um well it's everyone's business because
Jason's the one that's dead before that guard got killed I
mean Sophia I don't recall seeing you at all don't you even
think of blaming me okay I was with Ada the whole time it
all doesn't matter all Judging by the size of the dead
guard, it would have probably been very hard for a woman to
have done it.
Damn!
If it were me, personally, I would have run for the neck.
I would have killed him in a more brutal way.
It's kind of risky.
All in all, our killer was probably no professional.
So we're looking for a short man, you think.
Judging by heights, then, that leaves only our wobbly elder,
Rick.
and john wait i'm taller no one yeah while we were all out
we were all came back in here and john was last to roll in i
was in the security room like my clue was here i don't even
kill spiders makes you think i could kill a person that
makes jack our prime wait what how is me is the carving
knife i was literally with lynn and you just perjured
yourself against okay we were together and also jack no wait
and john that is what it was me and lynn the act guy and the
computer guy this game i had four people with me all i know
is i saw leon coming out of the puppet room after anna and
lynn and i left you checked the body he's probably off that
guard with his carbon
You guys don't understand this at all.
Doesn't matter.
Yeah, it was literally a woman's, like, shoes.
And we'll all be safe.
I saw the shoes.
No, no, no, Leon.
We're not voting innocent people out.
Are we?
That's murder.
Who cares?
Isn't this game just about surviving, about the skin of your
teeth?
No one's going to stay innocent forever.
Hmm.
Laughed easy.
You know, you're spending a lot of time, Leon, trying to
find out who the killer is not.
Maybe you're the one pulling the strings behind the scenes,
eh?
I agree with Len.
Time's running low.
Let's find out who the real killer is.
Having the killer hanging around could be dangerous.
I agree.
I'm sure some of us...
It's Amaga's time in the Junkler games.
As to who it might be.
Jack, I don't think we have time to know who the real murder
is.
is if we don't find if we don't vote someone out like right
now we might all end up dead together I'm voting to caring
and I don't fucking care if she didn't do it I hate it I
don't like her
yeah what are you guys looking at me for what you still have
time to backtrack save your own skin join forces with me
against so okay but he has like three people that hate me
already for me i didn't do it jack now is not the time for
compassion only bloodletting okay but his team has all the
people that hate me
sorry about destroying your your remote anyway get away from
me i'm with the voice hey i really appreciate you trusting
me to get that remote controller back i won't vote you out
but just remember people can flip quick so you better look
at saving your own skin rick thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you so good and so she saved the multiverse
let it be known everyone oh can't be trusted oh maybe i
should have given the remote we're gonna die here
there's no way wait it's oh it's leon okay of course i'm
gonna vote for leon five four three two one the time track
down the actual murder john's the only one without a solid
alibi his height and the crime time scene makes him the most
likely suspect but he did save me he's one of few friends i
have here leon went to the puppet room too so he's a suspect
But he's really good at rallying people up.
I'm going to go with A because he's like the scarier
opponent there.
I mean, B, if John's marinating me, then he's like the
ultimate villain.
But I think he deserves it if like he's trying to save his
girlfriend from embezzlement.
I understand, bro.
He wants to fix her.
Leon's ass lies might target me next.
What should I do?
A.
I vote for Leon.
Okay.
what five oh five votes also why did it go chinese i
why did it Chinese what
i died why don't you believe me i'm sorry jack i don't want
to die everyone's support looks like you picked the wrong
teammate Like what I said, kid.
It's tough to read people in this game.
For real.
How could you?
No!
I should have given him the remote.
I should have given it.
Good, awesome.
Wait.
Okay.
I have to.
If I vote John.
No, he still lives.
Okay.
We can salvage this.
We can salv- Someone will die here.
Wait, no.
Someone will die here.
Okay, wait, wait.
We can fix it.
Let's try.
Let's pick.
Oh, I just die automatically.
I still die.
It doesn't matter.
John, how could you?
I still die.
It doesn't matter.
I can't unlock this.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta...
We can do this.
Okay, we gotta...
We'll do this.
Alright.
Oh, she's not that.
Not that, though.
Skip.
Okay, we gotta do this again.
We gotta give him the remote.
Alright.
I can do this again.
again.
I remember.
Green.
Blue.
Wait, skip.
I thank God.
God, I'm such a.
I did find the remote control.
Did you find mine?
Yeah, I did it.
This is your remote control.
I know why there's a skip button on the mini game.
I believe in you, Doki.
Ask my friend Saul, give him a help you quick thank you
super chat i'm so nice i'll promise to give it to you but
you have to promise me that if you find mine you'll give it
to me without hesitation i was so smart we can help each
other out i believe in a soldier's word
you made a poor choice man bro i fucking died bro i know i
didn't make the wrong choice i literally died wait so the
picture on the phone okay continue all right we listen to
ada all right we know nice wig is a not the actual nice wig
just a future night not okay um homeless nice wig real nice
wig is a good guy he's a good guy Evil wig.
We'll call him Evil wig.
We know he's...
He still does that?
Sophia, what are you doing?
Well, don't forget.
This is a game of I die, you die.
Fewer competitors, and that means that I've got a better
shot.
Jack, you're way too naive.
Wait, does that mean she's still on my side?
I don't want to die.
You said you'd give mine back.
this world is all about strong survivors and you're just too
young to see the ugliness of human nature those cheese and
eyes I kind of envy you what the fuck Ada come on you're a
mom why are you being so cold-blooded it's for my kids I've
got to make it no matter what if my guess is right that
destroyed number nine remote control should be
anna's oh Sophia you bitch bitch oh chill out it's almost
time this is no time to fight okay now we continue okay now
I should have my votes right
The smarter you play this game, the more dangerous you get.
Ladies, ladies, that's an erasadoki for everyone.
Man's mind's unpredictable.
I'm only gonna make decisions that benefit myself.
You should think about the same for yourself, Jack.
Jack, I believe.
Yay!
We got him!
of time.
We just need to hurry up and vote.
We're all going to die here.
He works for me now.
Leon.
Maybe I can still get Leon out.
Oh, I have to vote for John.
Wait, I have his vote!
Okay, nice.
Oh, guys, I win.
What?
Why me?
I didn't kill anyone because you voted for you guys can't do
this it wasn't all to the version of you but you killed you
you voted for me bitch no I can't help trust you you voted
for me for me yeah like what I said kid it's tough to read
people in this game I fucking knew it didn't you vote for me
too I wanted to live just as much as you did sorry John
there's nothing I can do I knew it I I can't believe it.
Who betrayed me first?
You all just killed an innocent man to save your own skins.
You did the same!
Whatever.
Pretty soon you're all gonna know what this feels like.
Turn on the headlamp.
Why did it have to be you?
Yeah!
Zapping.
okay who else voted for me who's the other guy that voted
for me i wasn't checking
what the fuck jack
it was leon wasn't it we made it this far in the game what's
there to be afraid now yeah how could they blame thank you
make the super chat thank you bro jack what the fuck why are
you taking his belt like that ken was sorry to take me down
either i knew I need to survive.
Guys.
I think they weren't wrong when they said the game could be
four hours.
But I'm not going to lie.
I'm very immersed with this amazing writing.
Rolemakers must think that we're not motivated enough, which
is not very good for the game.
So using psychology.
and they're trying to provoke us with this dark spectacle.
All right, friends, let's embrace a new challenge to you and
remember the devil's got your back.
No!
It shouldn't be like this.
It's just a freaking game.
How did it turn into this?
Inside the game, it's real life.
What's
the...
Me?
Or you.
Or even you.
I don't want to die here.
My kids are waiting for me at home.
I can't survive for that week.
Anna, please calm down.
Okay, someone fucking turn her mic on.
They always forget to turn her fucking mic on whenever she
has died.
Hey!
Stay away from me.
Lynn didn't hurt anyone.
Plus, the game doesn't say that only one person can survive.
No one knows how this one.
get out a lot wow where did that come from screen i mean one
mistake and we're we're done you cowards oh you like hiding
well show yourself if you have the guts show yourself that's
enough hannah just isn't helping you need to stay awake all
the way from australia everyone listen up Fear and panic
will only send you to your doom faster.
If you want to survive, you might as well enjoy this wild
ride.
And don't be so soft.
I can't hear them.
I hope them.
Yeah, they should boot.
I need the piano to be a little louder.
I myself can't wait for the next round.
And I feel like a huge reward that's coming with it.
As expected.
Yeah, and it's good for...
They paid a lot for this...
For this piano music.
I'm not famous anymore.
It doesn't take anything away from your charm.
This damn game designer is pulling the strings on all of us.
Deciding who lives and who dies.
John wasn't even the murder of the Ace of Hearts.
And yet he died right in front of me.
No.
This isn't how it's supposed to be.
We can't let these people behind the game treat us like
puppets.
Oh my god, people love revolution!
You're right, Jack.
They don't say that only one person can survive to the end.
So let's say you and I team up.
You can split the prize money equally.
Oh, 500 grand each before taxes?
Bro.
Do I get taxed from an evil death game?
I don't really care about the prize.
That would be fucking crazy.
But if we join forces, we might actually be able to get out
of here.
It's like the lottery.
You won the death game and then you still get taxed by the
government.
I was like, kidding.
Imagine.
Gotta get out of here.
Yeah.
Jack, I still might be able to find a bug in this game.
After all, I'm a hacker and a good one too.
I trust you, George.
You're 19 and you experience the deep web, the dark web.
I trust you, but you really need to take care of yourself
first.
Bro, he does, he's like, he's accessed the dark web before.
And he's 19.
He's the hacker's man.
Look he's doing it now.
If you were as good as you said, you would.
were.
You'd have made it out of here already, young man.
As you can see, Jack is a game designer, George is a hacker,
and Lynn is a cop.
We have all these people here, and yet none of us can seem
to make it out.
Because we never work together.
Everyone who has tried is is dead.
So tell me, who can change this game?
All of us.
Nobody.
Oh.
The best you can do is survive to the end.
friendship and you know who wouldn't want that prize money i
need to win that money get my kids away from that jerk and
build them a better life
look okay i why does he need why do we have to let him end
up back on the street oh because he's homeless okay either
way it's no big okay evil wig i was gonna say why the do i
give him the money Oh, not the sick kid.
Are you counting on me to turn this around?
Oh, no.
I can't just leave them to hang.
Then, Jack, trying to escape might get us all killed, right?
I mean, continuing the game and trying to escape.
I'm not the sick kid.
Isn't it the point of this game?
Anna, we can't let anyone boss us around.
This isn't a game.
It's a straight up story.
daughter can't you see that don't you want to save lynn not
hungry i want to save her i want to save my waifu honor
think about your friend lynn you're such an ungrateful oh
that's not what in love with lynn that's not what i said why
you're a criminal profile right if you help me out I'll have
your back you're not grateful women I did not think I was
gonna say that it's literally the women derogatory bro I
don't I'm really I don't know I don't know if I'm good with
words guys but I talked to women but I have to figure out
the loophole in this whole game because behind this game
there must be a secret that i want to know and i believe it
must be connected to the conrad family i'm not about to let
them turn me into some sacrificial lamb i'm going to expose
them for what they really are
hello lamb i'm afraid it won't be easy for us to get out of
here safely in this current situation following me will be
dangerous you should think more about yourself and not
really have to be with me oh jack i believe in you i mean
face has got to be in our hands right we can't just give up
hug her don't worry he's like oh contestants are not allowed
to hug after the voting ends we're led into a new room the
common tune from behind the door might give us a chance to
catch your breath oh hey it's a strip club
whoa oh hey
hey guys yeah where's my car metallic 1926 you think she
took my cards after a hug there no that's way too smart
there's no way i didn't expect this looks like this place
isn't bad at all not every club is a strip club cash product
five million dollars yay
holy crap this looks like at least a couple of mil it feels
so great to have all this cash in front of me and i can
spend it as much as i want insane oh i'm oh Oh, the trippy
gas.
The smoke has a strange, pungent odor.
Oh, hey, my third one.
Dizzy, I suspect there's something off about it.
Oh, Jack, her eyes are up there, Jack.
Jack?
Or, oh, Jack.
Well, I like looked away.
I know for sure Jack's straight.
Okay, at least we know.
Wait!
male model okay guys wait okay guys wait
guys never mind B all right oh
what the fuck infinity and beyond What is this?
Hold left click to tilt the candle to fall.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I should have chose the circle, guys.
All right.
Here we go.
Let's go.
We're doing some candle art right now.
Okay.
I'm like, I did not realize.
All right, here we go.
What?
No!
No, I was laughing!
It's okay.
I just burned him a little.
It's fine.
A little burn.
Don't hurt nobody.
Guys, I know the sound is a little, a little awkward, but
we're in.
Oh, we got this.
Yeah, it's just a little moist Marshall, thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you.
I just remember Jack saw his girlfriend get shot in here.
Look, I'm grieving I love your work.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, I could talk to every I'll leave clown girl last.
Do you want to play a game with me?
Once you win, The treats I have waiting for you are simply
irresistible.
Except that this is what I see.
Zero, thank you for this.
Oh, it's like, oh, yeah, rock, paper, scissors.
We know what we want to pick.
Yeah!
That was easy.
He's like, um, I...
Oh!
Oh, tripped rock, paper, scissors!
All right, here we go.
Oh, my God, it always works.
Rock always wins.
oh oh oh no no
surely she'll use something different right yes I don't what
oh now she uses there is no way there is no way she used
paper three times okay there There we go.
There we go.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't hold.
I should have picked a rock.
Looks like he regretted accepting this act.
Oh my god.
Oh, a shoulder.
Oh, no.
Oh my god.
I got shown.
A shoulder.
all right what the fuck drop a mount the oh okay okay oh
it's just what is this all right mystery box yeah oh my god
it's the little oh it's just the stacker game all right how
much do i need anyway yeah we want to make sure we don't get
the bomb oh shit Wait, wait, wait, wait, I got this.
Oh, we got this.
Never mind.
Okay, instructions were very unclear.
Sorry, the instructions were just so unclear, guys.
I just, I wasn't sure.
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
I got greedy.
No, I cannot skip, but this.
okay as you don't understand the instructions were so
unclear that I was not very sure where to go okay oh my god
the bombs are glitched too like how the bombs are glitched
right now okay nice the never-ending bomb sound wait I think
that's a bombs there's no bombs responding anymore let's go
I win forever how much money do I didn't get
oh my god the bombs are back yeah
make it move make it rain alright continue
whoa oh yeah get off my woman oh
oh oh she showed her shoulders oh wait kiss oh oh oh what's
going on wait who is she who's dragging her away oh i'm
dragging her away that was me Lynn you have to wait Turn
over and claim dominance
Lolly thank you for the super chat Thank you thank you Thank
you Jack I did it Go check on Lolita and the other girls
Wait her name was Lolita Bro what I just realized one of the
fucking contestants is save lalita that's like crazy
look at them it's like ever since the game started everybody
started to cut loose and go wild yeah because we're drugged
up bro why do you think the manipulators are doing this i
can't imagine it's just a sweet and a deal for us it's not
for our benefit oh what's the range marriage girl they're
not very generous they want us caught up in our desires And
money is the quickest way to unmasking the darkest parts of
human nature.
Why did the manipulators do this?
I don't know.
Maybe to manipulate us.
Reminds me of an experiment that I was a part of once.
Pretty unforgettable.
What experiment?
You've worked for the Conrad family?
Curiosity can be dangerous, buddy.
Oh, hey.
Oh, she got some news for him.
Oh, that bitch.
Wife number two.
It's because she's mad.
She's not wife number one.
But I love to talk to you though.
Since your lover is a political rival of the Conrad family,
you probably know a thing or two about them.
Can you tell me something about the Conrad family?
Why are you so interested in the Conrad family?
Does it have something to do with you?
Well, no.
Actually, I have a feeling this game has something to do
with the conrad family maybe the information do not fall for
it again um fall for it again award goes to all right if i
remember correctly the last president of the conrad family
was assassinated was because of my ex he gave down specific
details about the president's travel plans and that's why
the she's the problem well not technically no she was just
there what does the conrad family not do they have something
beyond beyond the weapons like what that's a weapon tribes
in africa in exchange they're selling it to tribes and what
the fuck okay okay what Okay, imagine a fucking random
African tribe with a nuclear bomb Or like a bio weapon like
that's yeah, that's like riddles of the evil ass plot Yeah,
they fucking gave a tribe in Africa a fucking bio weapon.
That's crazy And that's Resident Evil 5 right now Of course
they are and that's part of why my ex was satirized
fascinated but I'm just one of his many flanks so I never
believed in me anyways if uh unlucky I mean that's a crazy I
mean if you told me your ex-husband is selling bio weapons
to tribes in Africa I'd be like what are you okay like I I
would not believe like the I'll be like the Resident Evil 5
fly how much you had just uh tiny little bit but can't you
see we've all been drugged you mean the spray earlier from
the start yeah they used to use it back there too oh back
where how'd you know that yeah the smell it smelled that
same way
do you guys use that spray when you fight first time to hear
no there's some mercenary uh domestication control type of
shape it was that stuff doesn't really help with conrad so
all of us here has connection with the conrad family i just
realized that we're all connected somehow or like some of us
are the strongest of course i used to run a squad that used
to get rid of all those terrorists
hey jack what do you say yeah i got a couple more drinks
tomorrow's not promised maybe he used to be an ex security
worker for the conrad family that's why he's homeless the
homeless guy i'll accept it Fuck it.
Let's go.
Let's, like, go.
We're home.
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's arm wrestling.
Okay, I thought he was telling me what drinks.
That's right.
Shit.
There you go.
That's right.
Not so strong now.
I have a wooden keyboard.
We're holding hands, guys.
Okay, what the fuck?
There's no way.
I should be winning.
Oh my god, bros, bros being bros.
We're holding hands very tightly.
Just the two of us.
There's a technique to arm wrestling.
You don't have to be strong.
It's just how you grip it.
Yeah.
right when did you get sober i might have stumbled upon some
useful info game designer strength yeah how does a game
designer win this oh let's go we're always method acting
right now what a crazy day
I like that.
Okay, that gets fun.
The guy on the cat, the guy.
The person who is likely responsible for assassinating the
last terrorists in the Conrad family is my father.
Sophia says her lover is probably the one who provoked my
father with the presidential itinerary.
Daniel, who used to work for the Conrad family.
Oh, it's all connecting together.
It's all coming together.
This part of a mercenary unit focused on capturing people.
terrorists oh daniel killed is just us suleiman's daniel
killed his father it's all connected the warriors protecting
our family yet we're labeled as terrorists the conrad family
commits countless despicable acts and gets away with them
what exactly have we done wrong it's because there are bases
that's everything and i will never let the history of the
sham be
all right the game goes on forever yeah i got it a cycle of
violence with no end you can't stand seeing it repeat can't
imagine how many lost souls so believe it's their only hope
they don't realize they're just lambs to the slaughter jack
i got a signal it's a relic again and this time there's an
extra word boomerang a club a boomerang what does it mean
yeah i i don't really get it either maybe it's boomerang
club nod i don't really know captain boomerang it seems
peter wants to lead the recipients to a certain place what
the fuck it's boomerang this matches nothing because it's
wood?
I would assume cellar because it's wood.
But like, the guard office looks really cool though.
What the fuck does Australia gotta do with lawn, cellar, or
a guard office?
Lawn because it's outside?
Oh, you play with one on the lawn!
Wait, you're so right!
I mean, you could technically pledge Looks like this answer
is wrong Okay, guys, come on I just have to wait till next
time to contact Peter Come on, I knew it I fucking knew it
was Seller God damn it
I fucking relic and Seller backwards I can't do anything
Until we figure out everything I'll go find Leon in the
other room first
Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah
Okay, wait, guys.
Oh, my God.
I think Relic is like, when you spell it backwards, it's
like cellar, right?
So that should be right it.
That would play the boomerang.
If Peter didn't want to tell us something, he would have
ignored us completely.
Wait, I think I bugged it out.
Or maybe correct.
And why did he reply with the word error?
And even if we can find the clues in this cellar.
Guys, I glitched it.
I messed it up, guys.
If we break in by force, we'll probably...
It's okay, it's okay.
We're just gonna look at this face.
But we're running out of signal.
The quicker we find an answer, the more response we might
get from Peter.
It's okay, it's okay.
It'll fix itself, guys.
Error is the answer.
Maybe it isn't a noun, but a verb.
Man, you're a genius, right?
told you to our answer to the clue but rather to the players
themselves if we make an error we will end up locked up so
we want to so we want to go to the cellar those who have an
error are locked up if so we need to check the answer again
no it's okay guys it's okay it'll fix when i get another
choice it'll fix itself guys i think i skipped but too hard
oh see there you go a new message George's watch the
beginning of eternally the end of time and space the dawn of
forever the sunset of time the beginning of end and the end
of every place the start of the end the finish of all places
yeah okay it didn't fix itself guys I have to go back I the
answer is wrong okay okay okay now we can watch this in
motion we still have a signal if Peter didn't want to tell
us something all right you guys listen to this i gotta pee
you guys can listen to the seller may be correct then why
did he reply with the word error and even if we can find the
clues in the seller how are we going to get there if we
break in by force we'll probably get discovered by the
guards i'm not sure but we're running out of signal the
quicker we find an answer the more response we might get
from peter
What if error is the answer?
Maybe it isn't a noun but a verb?
Lynn, you're a genius, yeah.
Error isn't referring to our answer to the clue, but rather
to the players themselves.
If we make an error, we will end up locked up.
So the seller is the place where those who have an error are
locked up.
If so, We need to check the answer again.
If there's a response, it means our guess is correct.
Oh, my God.
They're still going?
This cutscene was so long.
Oh, I just made it back in time.
Nexi, Diggs, Gordon, Sephora, Medi, Allen.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Yeah.
Perfect.
We got it.
We did it.
But we've lost the signal.
Peter's going to want to tell us more.
We have to plan our next move.
first try but what does the message mean it sounds so
philosophical but i don't even think they know what you're
talking about honestly i think we're just making up as we go
along i think the writers were like i didn't think this
person was gonna play this far into the game
he's like i didn't think you were gonna make it this far i
thought you were gonna get your refund i'll just need some
time this game is under strict surveillance If I cause
trouble now, I could be executed.
Even if I manage to get to the city.
Now you guys care about surveillance.
You've been fucking blurting out everything as we go along.
I miss the chance to find out the truth.
So I'll have to find another way.
Alright, sorry to commotion.
I gotta be a hero.
We have to make sure the guards lock us up.
Leave it to me.
I'm better at causing trouble than anyone else.
No, not the hackers, man.
no george is too damn yeah we gotta keep him alive and that
way even if he fails you'll be safe i agree maybe we'll find
nothing and maybe you can help us at the critical moment
from the outside sounds good in that case i'll be on standby
are you sure you want to do this with me we may not be able
to escape from the cellar yeah don't worry We'll do it for
love.
Thank you for the cheer.
George, you loser!
Get away from me!
Hey, what the hell was that for?
Hey, you be nice to her, otherwise I'll kick your ass.
Wait, isn't there so much?
Yeah, I was gonna say, are there people sleeping?
I didn't do anything.
She started it and cursed at me.
Oh!
Stop it, alright?
I'll let you fall.
As long as you won't let this slide.
She's gotta make it look good.
real again.
I'm so sorry, sir.
I didn't mean to hit you.
I was just trying to teach this damn girl a lesson.
He meant it.
Make them pray.
George, that looked real.
Get him, get out of here.
The one, that kicked it, George looked a little real though.
Doesn't seem to be in this room.
Seems like we can't get out.
Oh, it makes a word!
It's a G.
Amazing.
It's the alphabet.
But why put 26 letters in it?
Do you think this could be a clue from Peter?
It deals with me.
Beginning of eternity, the end of time and space, the
beginning of end, and that end of every place oh shit I
didn't pay attention because she was like she wakes at
interval she looking wakes at interval nice job nice job
Lynn nice job guys I don't even know what to pick guys wait
a second There are letters The beginning of every end what
what is it E?
It's like a she's never seen so many letters before Oh, it
gave me Trinity.
Yeah, it's E.
It's the first letter Yeah Is it an E?
Where's E?
And for the following three sentences each one represents
eat seems you found our answer that's the info i'm sorry the
way she said that was so good there's something inside how
the did she get into the interval
oh pita since you can see these messages you must know to
help me get out of here okay not gonna lie he looks like
what's his name the whistleblower guy from the a snowden
that's where he went yeah after he got he whistle blown he
went to play this
he went to try acting in this game
we found him guys we found snowden
i couldn't accept the sheer cruelty of what they were doing
but when i tried to escape game materials and expose their
plan oh my god he's gonna whistle blow oh my god he joined a
jocular he went to code for the jocular claims and now he's
gonna whistle blow the jocular games
it is him never escaped their clutches.
Edward Snowden starts with E.
That's why it's in E.
That person will be the only help to save everyone in this
cruel game.
Pleading the last challenge, the winners of each session
will all be sent to the secret room for psychiatrist named Z
here.
Alive.
Oh my god, the writing is actually too smart for us.
What's even happening?
He's whistleblowing.
Again!
He just can't stop.
The monitoring system.
I know a secret escape room.
God bless you.
Yeah, he's definitely looking down on the script.
All right, there's his...
There's the secrets.
I'm in.
Oh, there's the map.
Okay.
Found in the guard could be useful.
That's a secret.
What the fuck is secret?
Okay, lab.
Secret.
Event.
Well, we can't use this map now.
There's gotta be strict security in the VIP room with so
many celebrities there.
I don't think we can escape.
Just as I expected.
When I was investing in those missing people, a clown car
would pass by every time is that not suspicious a fucking
random clown car just like peterson it's all a conspiracy by
the conrad okay i didn't expect william conrad who is
running for president this time to be among them
Nice job, Interpol.
I feel like you would stop a clown car at that point.
To prepare for the next game.
I'm sorry, though, what now?
You must escape with the other.
Where are you taking us?
Oh, shit.
The raid is too smart for us because after two hours, the
king cries your IQ to the single digits.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, my God, bro, what the fuck?
now it's now saw now it's saw oh shit oh no it's fine I'm
Wayne oh oh is the bully oh it's a drama this is my
territory little brat I fucking He loves this game.
Whoa, backstory.
Okay, okay, excuse me.
Okay, apparently they did not tie.
They did not fucking restrain myself enough.
I just, yeah, I think they forgot to put ropes on my end.
No, I guess he even died up.
I'll live.
These bastards, the power of Shabu!
And expose all of this.
I remember you said you had read some old files.
How much do you know about the history of the Conrad family?
I read files about the Conrad family when I was dealing with
the case before.
But it was old, and the early materials about the Conrad
family were toned up.
Oh no, they were redacted.
Only detailed records on the remaining pages.
It's about a poker company named Kingdom in 1850.
At that time, Edward Conrad, the heir of the Conrad family,
added the Joker into poker for the first time and released a
comic book simultaneously.
I know that comic book.
My father showed it to me when I was a kid.
The comic book tells that the ancestors of the comic book
family won a battle and satirized the members of the royal
family of defeated countries in every possible way it's
extremely shameless they invented that joker the jungler
history about the karmic family nothing special just this is
the first game a streamer played that i have not attempted
to play it's okay guys i sacrificed myself so you don't have
to buy this game
I guess the Conrad family started their military industrial
business and gained political status after what they earned
The Conrad family has been doing evil the money and power
they have gained over the years are based on trampling on
the bones of other people's countries But with such a huge
foundation.
I love this game because it's like watching a bad movie, but
I can also play I can be involved in the terrible movie I
believe the truth will reveal one day
I could fund Junkler the Junkler games too I would love to
be an investor of the Junkler games for countless years my
father has fought against them
when I was a child my father always told me magical stories
before I went to sleep.
Okay.
Okay, that's AI.
Bro, they could have just got her.
Oh, yeah, no.
No.
Oh, my God.
I'm watching a fucking mobile ad right now.
saved the youngest prince and gave him the power of the
flowers making his decisions fight to recapture the ultimate
generations what the fuck was that scene I'm watching a
fucking movie I'll add a movie for the kiss yay
I deserve that kiss after I had to watch an AI cutscene.
Get some rest.
We have important tasks tomorrow.
Dominance claim.
I deserve that.
Chad, I knew you'd make it back alive.
I did it.
Oh, great.
I suggest you stop causing trouble.
We don't want to be involved.
Kid, what happened to you?
You look so pale.
It's nothing.
Just a small punishment.
Did you find any clues?
Yes.
There's a guards, didn't they have surveillance?
I think it's safer if you know less.
Why does everyone always treat me like a child?
Because you're 19!
Bro, you can't even drink in America!
According to what Peter said, the number of cards and chips
in the following game is very important.
but with the current discard pile on the big screen and the
cards of existing players i don't have an advantage i think
i need to have a private bet to get more he was on the dark
web though dokey monkey had to give him the welcome to
tomato fire welcome welcome george and lynn there are only
two people left in this room that i can choose from all
right what am i picking again i was not i was still like
shocked at what i just saw i was not expecting the fucking
ai cutscene there oh my god pick rick i'm still in shock oh
who would uh gambling with someone oh okay we'll pick rick
rick must have accumulated a lot of cards since the game
started and he didn't spend any at the bar he also has a lot
of He is a big fish besides Rick used to be a gambler If I
use my chips as bait, I think he'll be willing to bet with
me.
All right I'm lucky to be back alive tonight.
Hey, Rick, would you like to play a game with me to
celebrate my survival?
Yeah, let's yeah, let's let's do it.
Let's enable his addiction.
You don't want to bet with me?
I'd like to play it small So if we're gonna do this How
about Throw all your cards.
All right.
How about that?
Jesus, how did he have that many cards?
Okay, blackjack Okay
Okay, king queen jack and ten cards.
Okay, ace can cast one or eleven All right
Hit me Ten
King.
Oh, that's 16.
You know what?
Hit me.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I got too greedy, guys.
You lose, kid.
Oh, no.
You brought this on yourself.
no i thought it would be a different god jesus christ how
many fucking bro how many scenes did they film for this game
oh my god okay we gotta play dirty hey kid you're not gonna
fool me with that little trick of yours i'm not stupid like
lucas Oh, wait, I lose regardless, guys.
I don't think we should have gambled with Rick.
And now you gotta pay the price for getting caught cheating.
Jack has less than two cards in hand, so he is out.
No!
He's so resourceful!
He's been on the streets, guys.
He's been on the streets.
I just can't play Blackjack with him.
Wait, maybe it's this.
Okay.
I've got 10.
Okay, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't fucking matter.
Okay, we gotta go back.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'll just do that.
And then I'll go back to story that.
Okay, we gotta go here.
Oh, it's Skipper.
Skipper.
Okay, we gotta challenge Ada.
The other ones said that Anna and Ada are very dangerous.
Ada has a habit of stealing according to this inference the
person who stole Lucas and Smith's oh there's her kids Ada
so if I win her chips and cards it should be a great all
right yeah let's leave let's have the kids go to the abusive
dads let's go our session she didn't spend much if I use my
chips as a bait I think she'll be willing to bet with me I'm
lucky to be alive tonight hey Ada would you like to play a
game with me to celebrate my survival is there all my chips
and cards if you win they're yours yeah it's not doesn't
feel like a trap is in trouble you're plotting something
aren't you no there was only two options oh i'm still
playing blackjack okay i want to please my woman i just want
to win more chips to please lynn you know this woman is very
hard you better be careful romeo i'm not gonna go easy on
you oh my god Oh, Jack.
Oh, holy shit.
Every time Jack surprises me, I was like, is this to please
Lynn?
And he's like, you know, women are to please.
And I'm like, that is not what I thought he was, what I
thought I was going to say.
Yeah, the fact is like, I was like, yeah, to please my
woman.
No, I'm the reddest flag.
Hit me.
Okay.
You know what?
We.
Hit me.
I'll be greedy.
There's no way it's going to be another fucking 10, like
last time.
It's going to be the same, too, isn't it?
Oh, my God.
It's literally the same.
What?
Looks like luck isn't in your favor, Romeo.
Say goodbye to your lover.
Jack has less than two coins.
Oh, my God.
I think we have to cheat.
We have to cheat.
I don't think...
Wait, wait.
Does she have less than me?
Stay.
Oh my god.
She had less than me.
She actually had less than me.
Let's go.
I didn't even need a cheat.
Goodbye.
I saw her photo of you and your kids.
And I'm still gonna take your cards apparently.
Gotta please my women.
You know, it's very hard to please We have it you weren't
this pitiful when you stole Lucas's words you murder you
deserve this
Goodbye, she killed magic man wait we found out she killed
magic man was right she was the one who killed them oh my
god okay she deserved it she killed magic man between my
father and the conrad family must have something to do with
the solomon family history the comic book published by
edward conrad back then should tell you about the cruel
battle a thousand years ago now the conrad family is still
doing all kinds of evil impersonating game designers and
innocent people to make money the video just glitch for no
reason starting wars the solomon family are all the
persecuted oh there you go the conrad family just had didn't
have enough footage for the loot now the evidence i got in
the cellar is very crucial once the criminal evidence are
handed over to the political opponents of the conrad family
the conrad family will surely be defeated so i must take the
evidence impersonating game designers and starting wars do
the worst things you can do that's for sure We must ensure
George's safety.
And how would I...
Okay, okay.
This
game is fucking crazy.
This game is fucking crazy.
Jake, are you sure you don't want to come to my side?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
We'll be invincible.
Okay, I...
Okay, I will say that side has more allies.
What do you see?
It's like, Jack.
You should join us on this side.
Yeah.
Don't fall for that.
What the fuck would I join be?
Family reunion.
If we join forces, we could crush them.
Be rational, Jack.
It's like the super evil people?
Or like...
Oh, he's joining the super evil people.
Wait, why is...
Why is she joining them?
You're nice!
There's not enough chairs for all...
I'm joining it.
That's my first wife.
Okay.
there are 47 cards in total consisting of 23 matching cards
okay you sell cards that card must be the lucifer and your
team loses you have no cards left your team if you have no
cards left your team
wins okay choose a player team draw at the same time other
players will push her matching pairs are oh okay all right
we just have to match her cards this is a little oh i've
never played
i'm joining group a so it seems we're on opposing sides jack
all i can do is wish you good luck we have a cheater a
psychopath and what the fuck okay we have a cheater a
psychopath and a homeless guy on team b and also the little
girl all right i'll select leon okay
my remaining cards okay what is the lucifer card wait she's
done kid you got about three cards left and it's pretty
likely you got the lucifer card now it's my turn to draw a
card let's make a bet how do you want to bet let's each take
out a card privately and exchange them you get a Lucifer
card, and you'll make a pair, and you should have one card
left.
If I win the bet, I'll just make a pair, and I'll have no
cards left.
And I think from there, we can assume which one's the
Lucifer card.
Jack, I think the Lucifer card is in my hand.
Why do you think so?
Because that card passed through my hand twice before, and
each time I couldn't make a pair, it's back again.
What should I do?
Hmm.
If we use Rick's method and exchange the card, you think is
the Lucifer card to me.
Maybe we can find out whether it is or not.
However, there is also a risk.
After all...
She would never lie.
She's so innocent.
It is weird that she's on the...
She's on the evil team.
To win the game, it definitely sent me the Lucifer card.
No way to defeat Rick is to out cheat him in this match.
And she's sitting too close to the cameras.
Shooting cards is rigorous and cheating would be easier to
spot.
I have cheated gaining the upper hand.
Rick seems like a safer bet.
Now, what's the best move?
Okay.
I can decline the trade.
A trade.
There's no way.
Children never lie.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Why did I do that?
J for Jack.
Okay.
LaLita again.
Unfortunately, Team A has the Lucifer card and is out.
What?
Congrats to the winning group.
The losing group, please head to the loud.
We have prepared a chance of surviving one person.
Please claim it yourselves.
What?
The child lied to me?
Looks like you picked a wrong opponent.
This bracelet symbolizes good luck in my village.
I hope it gets you out alive.
She gives me a fucking bracelet.
She's like, here's a bracelet.
You set me up!
Bro!
How is that good luck?
If there is more than one person left at the countdown, it's
over.
Everyone was over.
Good luck.
Oh, no.
We can't all get out alive.
I didn't want it to come down to.
Oh, no.
I thought we're the dream team.
I got a wife and a sick daughter that are counting on my
survival and on this prize money.
Y'all can come try.
oh my god it's a free-for-all there is no much time left
daniel is too strong we need to get him first all right
everyone just oh he's just gonna he's gonna get that axe and
he's just gonna swing it at him oh my god he's just he's
gonna kill george oh george okay um okay um
Jack, you need to survive.
Explore the horror family, okay?
What is that even me?
What the fuck is like a plastic axe?
No, no, I'm just...
I think they stopped blowing him yet.
I did it.
I am stronger.
Absolute cinema.
oh my god he he oh my god i can never win this fight wait
this is actually unwinnable that there's no way you cannot
win that one like game designer strength oh my yeah it's
like all the way to death that's crazy wait can i like oh my
okay rick Get the auto-clicker.
Bro, that...
I still lose!
Oh my god.
There's no other way.
Okay.
I have to cheat.
That's crazy.
Kid.
I have to trade with Rick.
Okay.
Play dirty.
Bad luck for me this time.
Oh, nice!
We did it!
Congrats to the winning, the losing loop.
Please head to the loud.
Goodbye.
The loss.
I had to cheat.
Goodbye.
We can get out of here alive.
Please take this bracelet back to my village and give it to
my mother.
She was still suffering from a strange illness when I left
and other villages...
Okay, she is not too scared of a fucking guy.
I prefer you give it back to her yourself.
Oh, she knows she ain't surviving.
100% Leon's gonna survive.
Either Leon or...
Or Evil Whig.
That's actually crazy.
The fucking...
great acting george bravo george was an amazing actor there
what's going on in there when he got it said there's a
chance of survival it doesn't sound good don't be stupid
there's no such chance i mean only one one of them can
survive that was absolute cinema george was so good my
money's I mean, after all, he's competing with pensioners
and entertainers, right?
It's not.
I don't know, Daniel.
Jack, what do you think?
Yeah, why would it matter?
Oh, is Leon back?
What?
Back?
I'd rather stay.
Wait, don't you?
She killed Leon!
How could she kill the homeless guy, too?
These innocent lives were brutally killed in this damn game.
The so-called upper class is crazy.
She, what?
That is the biggest plot twist of this game.
That was the biggest plot twist we got.
Watching them fight brutally as fun in games.
This killing game must end.
I can't watch all this keep repeating.
She third party.
I refuse to believe she killed Leon.
balance and control oh my god guys guys i see the light guys
the reaches its end game word this is that this is the last
chapter but can you make the right cop how do you save
everyone how do you stand against this monstrous family can
you save your loved one or is there truly no way out the end
game
oh hey okay that looks that looks good though oh my wait
that actually looks fucking good i'm fucking i'm not dinner
yet i'm hungry now i'm gonna mix some i bought some
meatballs from costco some swedish meatballs
oh the fact that they had there's no way they actually got
that custom made they must have bought that bulk from like
timu or some shit i refuse to believe they bought this
custom made i feel like you find the fucking jungler pin
somewhere so the black joker is finally appeared ikea's just
so far from me costco's close to i don't have it who do you
think has it none of us show our cards to others if i say
don't have it We don't even know if the cards really exist
or not Maybe it's a plot made by the game manipulator But if
somebody really has the card That doesn't mean that they
will win Yeah, I love the background dancer But look at her
go The final showdown is coming, you know, she's not even
singing anything.
She's just like she's just like like painting it too she's
not actually like singing the backup dancer in the
background she's literally just making lip movements they
literally just told us that we can move freely tonight since
we arrived when do we she's actually the piano right now
you're actually a lot smarter than you look however i'd
strongly recommend that you nor anyone else try me those are
cute earrings though i have more expertise i like that is
that combined come on you don't have to be so hostile yeah
she's actually coming the piano we can all survive this
place don't be silly you actually believed in those nonsense
we all came up with those lies to comfort ada since the
beginning we all knew that only one player is walking out
without one billion dollar price
Since the final showdown is tomorrow, it would be a pity to
die tonight.
So I advise you all not to take risks.
It's better to have a good rest for tomorrow's fair
competition.
Oh, hey, the chocolate's back.
The Ferrero chocolate is back.
God, that looks so good.
Fine, Anna.
Fine.
Why the fuck would I...
Okay, I'm finding Sophia.
I was like, why the fuck would I, anyway, I'm going to find
Sophia.
She fell for it again, guys.
Jack, if I really die tomorrow, will you miss me?
Of course.
But I prefer you to be fine.
Doki fell for it again.
And I'm really good with confronting women.
I dealt with a lot of men in my life, and you're indeed very
special.
Gosh, she called me special.
It was all worth it.
If I wasn't here, I would have really wanted to be in a
serious relationship.
Oh, gosh, see, look.
Silly me.
I thought coming here would change my miserable life.
I can't fix it.
I can finally stop playing up.
those stinky men and finally act in the movies i like having
the lifestyle i always want okay you're not acting i don't
think you wanted to be here i just
stuck in this loophole and it's never ending and i can't get
rid of it
that does not look like what that looks like great juice
guys Sophia you are a really good I mean like in comparison
to like in relation to the others on this game yeah you can
get out alive you can start over and be the queen who never
bows her head again can't you see this whole world is a
stage all the men and women they're all players in this game
and in this game Everyone is so hypocritical, saying love
words while holding knives in their hands.
This is exactly the wonderful human nature all these
manipulators want us to be and that's what they want to see,
you know.
All the world's a state.
What is that?
Yeah, I was gonna say, was that from fucking Shakespeare?
Because everyone in my eyes is so real and vivid, and so are
you.
Whoa.
Sophia, you can regard this game as your grand performance.
I hope you enjoy your highlight.
May you have a good show tomorrow.
Damn, that's so deep.
Damn.
That's deep, bro.
I've never seen a man so sincere as you.
No matter how bad the people in this game are, I hope you
never change.
You must get out alive I also believe that where there is a
dream there is light what
What is that quote?
Well, I feel like they got that like shows me a deadly troop
behind this.
She doesn't even get a real seed and drag a soul from heaven
to hell without a sound then why bother living at all and i
chugged a whole beer bottom burst into tears i should
probably say something okay thank god i was gonna save that
was all that was crazy if i'd even get it at a siege he's
the reason why i'm here trapped in this game i'll be crazy
trust me jack i've got nothing to lose It seems you don't
want to survive tonight.
If you get drunk, you'll be an easy target.
Bro, if this script was AI generated, I will not be
surprised.
Oh my, like, guys, you know what they say?
Like, AI is going to fucking make video games.
I, you know how they said, like, Elon Musk is like investing
in AI to make actual full-on games?
I do not think after playing this game, I think game
developers are safe.
I...
I think I think game developers and game writers are safe
right now.
We will see who end up dead Please Jack I only a accurate
right.
It's the alphabet.
You think I don't see clearly in your game?
Please you better be careful tomorrow.
Oh My god No, Fano, you'd better stay sober.
This is all I i can say i'll leave you alone thank god this
was on steam cell thank god human nature has no bungees
shamu what is this like like deep talk right now i'm having
a deep talk with chat gpt yeah it's actually been really
helpful i downloaded the information onto my and got into
the castle night for him.
Problem is, I still can't find Peter's location.
And without that, there's nothing we can do.
Thank you for trusting me, Jack.
And I'm sorry I let you down.
Peter should be safe for now, George.
If we have a chance to get out alive, we'll definitely find
a way to save him.
Okay, George is way too good for this game.
I'm sorry.
Like, this guy is like...
Like, he does not deserve to be in this game.
I mean, despite all the help from the real...
This kid...
Like, he deserves better.
He was severely underpaid.
He's way too confident.
He's giving too much.
I might die tomorrow.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, he's doing a favor for a homie.
But I haven't said goodbye to my parents, Jack.
I hope George lives.
I just want to say goodbye.
Bro, George deserves it.
Oh, sorry.
This game doesn't deserve him.
No!
The fact that he's able to act out the fucking axe fight
and, like, now I don't think they had multiple.
takes for that he fucking sold it even without the blood he
did the fact that he didn't crack my parents are always so
busy with work i always tried to get their attention but
never seemed to work even if it was just for a moment you
know one small compliment to get me through the day oh
georgie now of course i realized it bro i would hire this
man Because what if I hire him to do something for me?
I'll fucking look him up on credits.
If I'd run away from home like the idiot that I am, I'd
still be with them right now.
At the dinner table, eating my mom's shitty mashed potatoes
and white pudding.
When you get home, say hello to your parents for me.
Then invite me over for dinner.
I want to find out how bad those potatoes really are.
him.
I want a cameo from him.
You might be the most handsome man.
It's true.
And when you finally make it out of here.
I'm gonna make you a star, Georgie.
I want you to take me with you, Jack.
Well, Jack's giving him nothing.
He's trying so hard.
I don't want my life to end.
just beginning yeah game data has been refreshed well i
don't think i'm the most handsome man i'm definitely not
afraid of death tomorrow we'll fight till the very end bro
george is too good bro he's the fact that he's able to
fucking act this out thank you for guiding me through this
the script that he had i wasn't following the wrong person
if only you can get out alive in the end.
Tell my mother that actually her mashed potatoes and white
pudding are not that bad.
Tell her I love her.
Holy shit.
All right, Daniel, your wife and your sick kid.
Brought a couple cold ones if you want one.
I feel like the longer we go, the more we realize they
started having less and less budget.
Only because like in the beginning, I didn't even realize.
realize it was like AI like they use AI for stuff and then
it got like except for the funky photo of the kid but the
more the closer we get to the end they're like okay we throw
AI in here because in the beginning the beginning half it
still felt like it was written by a real person oh yeah of
course it's cancer okay it's always like if it's a sick kid
it's always cancer like of it felt like a real person was
writing it it was really bad but like it still felt like a
person actually sort of wrote it and then then it got like
worse and worse men
brothers who would have sacrificed for each other were now
sacrificing one another all i know is that had i not escaped
and went into hiding who knows what i've ever been forced to
have done to my brothers but ever since have been labeled as
a deserter.
You're not wrong.
You're not a deserter.
Your escape is resistance against inhumanity.
As long as you're alive, there's one less sacrifice and
warrior in this world.
You are that warrior.
I am being that warrior.
I can't even say that.
save my daughter my mom you take two can you say that again
each and every single day my daughter jenny is six and i
don't even have the money to cure her illness what kind of
what kind of warrior am i what kind of man is that
i know it's that melts my heart every time that little girl
calls me daddy what where did that come from your only angel
he's like my daughter is sick protect her oh i love it
whenever she it always makes me so happy when she calls me
daddy jenny and your wife are waiting for you at home right
now
you know what jack i'm really glad i met met you man you
kind of you kind of got me feeling like i'm back with my
brothers in the trenches you know fighting alongside my
military boys thanks bro oh it's a homie i really want you
to meet her you gotta meet you have but honestly if if
jack's a brother if you're alive can you promise me you
should go visit them oh my god so many people have to visit
guys if you win the grand prize i have to visit his wife and
dying kid if you can just and then george's mom and then um
oh at least the actress has no one thank god daniel you're
gonna win the grand prize and you're gonna handle that on
your own Okay, but if he wins it, then that means like we
all die You're my brother for real Jack.
Hey my brother for real Cheers
Thanks, man, just so you know in the every other timeline
you fucking killed me Kid don't you die here.
I want you to see how lovely my little angel is All right,
Lynn We saved the best for last
No matter what challenges we face tomorrow.
I will be there for you Wait, did the voice act?
Wait, was the voice over AI?
Bro, the guy didn't come back to even fucking read the extra
dialogue He like fucking checked out afterwards.
At first I insist on doing this case And I made a solo
request to my director Yeah, I didn't even come back to
record the final dialogue They had to use AI this game.
It's not the end yet.
You haven't.
I bought this just to show you guys.
What a I didn't even know this game was AI.
I just thought it looked funny for us to help because I read
the reviews like so bad that it's good.
I was like, that seems fun.
No, it's still.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Literally they're like it's so badass kid.
I was like oh, I love playing those types of games You know
like bad movie watch-alongs.
So I was not expecting The AI stuff Everything that happens
here It's like a nightmare I want to end this Because I
played like FMV games before uh they're like like i don't
know if you guys remember but i played like several fmv
games before there was one that was also battle royale i was
like oh those are fun no matter what nightmare it is it will
end and i won't forget that it's been in my life i didn't
realize it could make it could do so much ai yeah this is a
public service announcement about the dangers of shitty ai
involvement we were the reason why i'm still alive No matter
what happens tomorrow, get out here alive.
Yeah.
I won't leave you behind, Lynn.
We will leave together.
Jack, if we can survive and get out together, I will never
leave you for the rest of my life.
Wait, I think that was AI too.
No, George came back.
George is a real one, guys.
He's a real one.
He's a professional.
He fucking came back to do his voiceover and no one else
did.
Yeah.
Well, since we are all allowed to...
George is the pro.
It makes more sense that we spend the night together, all of
us.
I mean, Sophia and I, two women.
I did not realize that I got this bad.
in another room who knows who could come because I would
assume it would I would be like you know other games but I
didn't think like I thought like for FMVs you know
militarily trained FMVs I would not expect AI to have such a
heavy involvement don't worry Anna I'll protect you I just
thought I just backed acting and writing just like Jackson
tomorrow's game couldn't be fair
I have to hide and georgia this is under man thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you anybody else i only trust
him it depends on jack i'm not fucking sleeping with sophia
lynn's my rider die she my rider die sorry the position you
killed four girls or not even girl you killed four people
sophia
Seems like Jack is madly in love with you.
Yeah, no fucking shit.
You're all fucking murdering one survivor Will live tomorrow
if it was just four people you guys are more painful.
Yeah, she's the six to my seven guys Remember that.
I don't envy you as much anymore Guys, we're a match made in
heaven Jack do you know where the black Joker is?
I guess you have it How did you know you know that a long
time ago?
Judging from everyone's reactions now you're the most likely
person to have the black Joker Even if I win I may not be
able to get out alive See you guys we're perfect for each
other I want to give this card to you.
Oh my god.
Look at that At least you have a better ride or die
Actually, I do have a better idea ride or fucking die but
it's a little risky after all i'm not sure if the bug will
work if you want to survive in this game how can you avoid
the risk see guys yeah worked let's give it a try it really
did about the specific plan i trust you whatever the outcome
is we'll take it together
Did we none of us bring like take off your jacket?
You do not oh wait, what's going on?
Sophia.
Oh wait, no, Anna.
No, George!
George, you!
It seems that they want us to kill each other tonight.
The guards or drones won't come until morning.
Anna, even if you do manage to take other things, can you
guarantee that you won't be attacked by others.
Shut up.
Don't come near me.
I will kill her.
Anna, Lynn is your best friend.
She came to this game for you.
You can't do this to her.
Beth, man, don't think of her as so selfless.
She came here to investigate the case and get promoted.
I mean, best friend.
You all agreed to help me find Jason.
And what did you do when he was dead?
You did nothing!
Well, you did nothing on it.
Anna, don't be impulsive.
We will find Jason, okay?
After we get out, we will avenge Jason.
Avenge!
But there's no need to avenge!
I killed Jason!
I fucking knew it!
That was women's shoes right there!
Crazy?
Why did you do this?
How dare you ask me why?
Why?
What were you doing?
What?
I know I was doomed, but unexpectedly I saw Jason.
I cried and I begged him.
I begged him for him to save me.
Begged him too for him.
But he wanted to save me.
He wanted to report me.
That's heartless scumbag.
A scumbag.
He was trying to say scumbag.
I came to this damn hell to find him and he left me to die.
How crazy is that, huh?
I mean, if I had more time, I would have stabbed him a few
more times, you know?
I did not kill Jason.
I did not.
Oh, hi, Anna.
So I take you with a super chat.
You know, the game rules.
You know, if the room came out in our time, it would have
been with AI as well.
I have the feeling.
100%.
That movie would have been made with AI.
You can only count on yourself in this game.
I will not let anyone get in my way tonight.
I'm going out alive.
Is George okay?
Well, I don't think so.
Now Lynn's life and the Black Joker are mine.
What the fuck?
Kill Anna.
And I'm going to split.
wins chips and cards with you equally of course except for
that black joker but how did she know why did you why did
you not you slept with your coat but not with your fucking
cards
okay um
okay well we'll we'll Anna, your life is in Sophia's hands
now.
Why don't you let Lynn go and we can consider helping you
deal with Sophia together?
But you must promise to leave two cards for Lynn.
Jeff!
Are you crazy?
Oh!
I got her, guys, don't worry.
I got her to chokehold, guys.
Why couldn't you do that, guys?
I'm sorry, there's no way she's dead.
There's no way.
When George survived.
George lives.
According to the current game design, 52 people represent
the 52 cards in the deck excluding the two jokers.
Bro, what kind of joke on was that?
He fucking snapped her deck.
have the rest of the cards the cards i have are fun no
matter what kind of game my chances of winning are quite
high according to what happened to jason even if i win by
chance i may not be able to escape but at least i get to
stay alive but if i use rick's cheating skills and magic
temperature card tomorrow i will have to say you know what's
actually crazy this ai voiceover can't identify
Whoever the fuck is playing, Jack.
That's the saddest part.
So what should I choose next?
That's actually crazy.
The AI voice acting is giving me so much more than whoever
is Jack right now.
All right, fight back.
We gotta fight back against the system.
That's right.
Not the Jack-Oz.
Thank you for listening to chat.
Hey, guys.
Thank you.
What are you thinking, Jack?
This ain't no regular or average war that we're fighting
here.
But I do think that since we've all gotten here this far,
where there's a will, there must be a way.
Dude, there's a will, there's a way.
I don't want to give up on your goals, but whatever your
plan is, it's too risky.
And if it fails, None of us will be lucky.
Risky?
Aren't we risking our lives right now?
So many people have died, and we're about to end up the same
way.
Who now stands a chance tomorrow?
George?
Daniel, what about you?
Do you even have a 50% chance of winning?
You don't, do you?
Lynn, trust me.
I can't guarantee success.
But I know none of us four want to see the others die.
at the current odds each of us only have a one in four
chance of survival but if we join hands we will have a 50%
chance of survival do you want to be slaughtered like those
other 48 victims what's the point of dying in such a stupid
way George it seems that you're just an immature child and
should go back to your mom and make white pudding no don't
say that a brat who runs away from
mic guys the mic bro you're moving too much jack jason is
the best you take that back they won't let the way he's
doing his best maybe they won't give us the money at all
only when you get back to your wife and daughter will you
have a chance to save them do you understand stop eating the
mic bro if it were your father standing here he would never
be as
There's no such thing as luck in this world.
We have to fight for everything.
Only in this way can we change our fate.
Bro, I won't be surprised if they did one take for this.
Maybe she's right.
Bro, I won't be surprised, bro.
That's why I'm saying George.
Guys, how do you send your team on three?
Guys, team on three.
I should do it with you guys.
there's no way i swear they say team i swear to god
that's what okay back into the ai system of the castle
peter's ai system is too powerful i can't get in try sending
the code to contact peter he must have a way that's the
first thing i tried to do but unless he senses that's crazy
that they like hyped up leon for so much so much and then he
dies to Sophia.
The auto network should be able to control the receiver on
his colleague.
Can you do something with it?
Bro, they can't believe it.
They killed the psychologist, but he could read our minds.
According to my observation, the only room that hasn't been
used so far should be the location of tomorrow's game.
And at the end of this floor, the VIP room has the highest
security.
It will take six minutes for all the guards to come from the
rooms on both sides of the VIP room to our game location.
We only need to find out Peter's position to calculate the
time to rescue Peter and then escape through the air ducts
This camera is too good for what the fuck we're doing
The lighting and color grading is better than wicked is
fucking surprising That's the saddest part Definitely gonna
be a lot of this this color comp with this conflict with the
guards This seat has better fucking colors than wicked.
Oh my god.
Look, look.
It's Peter.
He said...
Are you crazy?
Do you want to die?
Peter sent us a code.
I think we can use this to find his location.
We're here.
Peter replied?
Great.
Mr. Snowden?
We can calculate that it will take about three minutes to
get from you.
I believe Peter Snowden supports AI.
Daniel and I will be responsible for resisting the guards.
That's why he's whistleblowing, guys.
George to save Peter.
He's trying to fight against AI.
He's whistleblowing.
Daniel and I will attract all the guards.
If we can't escape, Peter and George will be our last help.
Peter, the guy that's off screen.
This is all the evidence that can destroy the Conrad family.
must do everything we can to keep the evidence to escape
from this he ran out of footage guys tomorrow when the first
person is out yeah what about shabu explain what happened to
shabu everyone should hurry up and no i legitimately think
they just ran out of footage here there's no way yeah they
did they fucking did they forgot to record additional
footage making this game oh my god because we I think I can
use this copy of the black joker to confuse the AI that no
matter who is out, we can use it.
That's crazy.
I gave you the black joker already.
There's no need for you to take it.
You watch such bad animation.
Once the system you recognize it, you will surely die.
Whether I can hold on or not, I hope you can survive.
I didn't expect Lin-Rosa to sacrifice herself for me.
I don't know whether I would meet a girl who loves me as she
does if I could really leave here.
But if this fake black joker doesn't work, I might die
tomorrow.
Maybe even Lin-Rosa can't tell which one of your own names.
Bro, why could you get him back to record this?
I'll give the real black joker to her.
She's my girl.
Ride or die.
They are God.
They're not coming back.
out jacko has my goat is back bro just called him up on
discord just do a sky like a zoom call it doesn't even find
a way for me and you to survive together
oh nice
roll the streets with everyone watching
well george committed to the end He a homie for real
When your voice actor doesn't even return the dm
All right Texas mania each player selects two whole cards
from their own deck as their hand the dealer Revealed
Communion cards.
First round.
Reveal 3.
And can heal all 5.
Communion.
After each reveal.
Players may choose to raise.
Bold.
Jesus.
How do I play this?
Okay.
I've never played Texas Holden before.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait.
I think I got it.
I've never played poker.
I'm going to learn poker right now.
Okay.
I'm gonna learn poker right now, guys.
All right.
Um, Queen King.
Wait.
Or, like, maybe...
Yeah, Queen King.
There you go.
I'm going in strong.
Rez.
That's right.
Okay.
Guys, I don't remember.
Yeah, but that could get Jack.
An ace, too.
Or Joker.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, there's Jack.
Raise.
Wait.
There's Jack.
I actually got Jack.
Guys, there's gotta be an ace.
There has to be an ace.
Two.
okay check
I can't raise anymore they won't let me raise yeah nice I
couldn't I wanted to but I couldn't I went all in though I
did go all in
guys I think I might be a natural at poker I think guys guys
I think I'm just naturally gifted at poker guys oh my god i
get jack and ace and then wait maybe i could do eight and
wait maybe jack and ace and then maybe i could get queen and
king oh that is so risky or nine and ten i'm a natural
natural
what do we do nine and ace or nine or Jack and Ace or Jack
and Ace?
Okay, all in.
Confirm.
Oh, bro, this game better not do this to me right now.
Guys, I think the game crashed.
We were so close.
We were at the finish line.
Oh my god, they can't do this to me.
I was so close to the end where am i where am i oh my god
what okay there's like three okay that has to we're like
there we're actually there like take me back okay there we
go okay queen king that's what we're at right all right
we'll just keep going I'm just going to fucking raise it up.
Straight in.
We already know.
It has to be like...
There you go.
It has to be the same.
I just went all in.
Oh, wait.
Jack.
Oh.
Wait.
It's not scripted.
What do you mean this is?
isn't scripted.
Okay, wait.
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh, a pair of queens.
We do have a pair of queens, though.
We don't over till it's over.
Oh my god, I still won.
I got a pair of queens.
Let's go.
Skip.
Okay.
9, 10.
I'm all in.
That's right.
All in.
I got more chips than last time.
Oh, pair of tens?
I mean, that's fine.
Oh.
Got pair.
Oh, nine, ten, uh, nine, ten, king.
Okay, I just need a queen.
Guys, don't say that.
I bet I went all in.
Oh, my God, 60,000.
wait how many rounds is this like i literally just won 60
000.
there's no way they could keep going
there's no way they could keep going six rounds bro i could
just fold
wait jack ace bro i can literally just fold and then we're
done we're done let's just i don't will call a thousand.
I have so much money.
There's no way I could lose.
There's no way any of these people are catching up.
Wait.
Pair of jacks?
There's no way.
I'm too lazy.
I'll pay I'll bet like 30 grand.
Yeah, I got a pair here.
Guys, I couldn't keep going.
It was too far.
There was just I had too much money to keep betting.
It's 94,000.
I raise.
There's no way these people have the same amount as me.
They've lost every fucking one.
Yeah!
George looks started out of nowhere.
What's the matter with him?
Could we be at least out of both cars and chips?
George!
Oh, your buddy!
Come on, let's go.
Ow.
Oh my god, he's still alive.
Tokey, you killed him.
Tokey.
Jack, what do we do?
I can only vote to close 20 minutes.
Oh, shit.
The word, boom!
Boom!
That was surely...
Okay, it worked.
We did it.
Lynn!
Take George, go find me.
Royalty-free pal.
And we got this.
He was in the military.
From where?
Boom!
Hey, Jack.
Yeah?
Which way do you think we should go?
Um, pro, what?
This decision will reshape the entire...
Okay.
Um...
You know what?
what let's go through the main door it has the green joker
the jonkler there what does this mean I'm afraid we have to
crack it to open the door they're catching up hurry Jack
alright let's push the crate real fast alright
okay I've done this in PokeMaz before.
It's easy.
Okay.
Guys, I've done this in PokeMaz before it's easy.
Okay, okay, here we go.
Okay, there we go.
We did it.
did you get the things from the cellar i went to the cellar
here's all the stuff wait mr snowden wait wait okay he was
just locked there evidence of the conrad family if we can
expose this to the public they're doomed where did he come
from we gotta get out of here asap yeah but we can't
guarantee that we can get out alive even if we die here the
evidence must not be up George Peter also what was the fuck
was up with the bully scene when I had my flashback my
computer is the only way to make contact with the outside
world but its stability is not guaranteed although I know
its source code the AI system is self-updated I'm afraid I
can't do it with my ability I might be able to do it my
watch but jack you've got to be sure about this if i
transmit that evidence we'll lose five oh you did not
deserve you did not those shields go down these things
around our neck will kill us hurry up george i'm so sorry
bro you deserve better guys even though we played this what
we went through with this game the we discovered george guys
we There is a bright side to this.
We discovered George.
Unfortunately, even if God was here, himself, we wouldn't be
able to do anything.
I mean, I'm going to take a line from the top.
Unfortunately, even if God was here himself, there's nothing
we can do.
Peter, you designed the system perfectly.
I mean, even though we breached the system, it would take us
at least 10 minutes to stabilize the transmission.
That's not time we have.
we're gonna die maybe I can also contribute I'm a game
designer time to five minutes maybe we can succeed but we
may not be able to get out of here alive no no George
deserves to go back and eat the pudding he might have died
he deserves the pudding but so long as, but even if we don't
make it, so long as we can save those innocent people and
make those bastards pay, who would have just redoed the
reading.
They just left it in, no time.
I'm willing to die.
Yeah.
I never thought I'd be a hero trying to save the world, but
I guess today I am.
Let's do this.
Let's give it a shot.
Friends, it's my pleasure to know you.
We've gone through a lot.
That was a critical moment for us to protect those innocent
people.
Whatever the outcome is, we will do our best.
Even with the last bit of strength, we will let the enemy
know our determination is unshakable.
Today, we fight for glory, for the light of justice in our
hearts and our common mission.
Jack, shut the fuck up.
I just want to hear George.
oh my god control pac-man from what control pac-man with
okay legally they're not okay that's okay i don't think i
don't think pac-man is aware of this eastmongston you clear
the stage okay we're playing pac-man now we're playing
pac-man yum yum it's pac-man time i'm actually really bad at
pac-man though like unfortunately i am not that good at
pac-man it's not even not it's legally distinct pac-man is
that it left pac-man in there That's fucking crazy.
Oh, the worst part is I'm actually very...
No!
It's one life!
Okay.
This is bad, guys.
I'm actually really bad at Pac-Man.
Okay.
I just somehow always pick Rod.
Okay, there you go.
We just have to...
in a way.
I technically don't have to eat them.
Because I just have to...
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, I don't even have to grab all of this.
I just have to grab the chips.
Oh my god, I just have to grab the chips.
This isn't even full backpack.
I just have to grab the computer chips.
I just noticed.
I thought I had to grab everything.
These materials will be sent to any host on a public
network.
Guys, he's a game designer, guys.
They're coming.
George, Peter, protect the computer.
Don't let anything happen to the transmission process, no
matter what.
Jack, we're at 79%.
Just hold him off a little longer.
Who are you?
Shoot him!
Oh my god!
Oh, they can't even get the blood splatters!
Oh shit!
99%.
How did he fall down?
We are doing the fight.
Brothers, we are winning.
For a world of freedom.
and peace wait his thing is going off he didn't even cut it
brothers what for freedom are they getting zapped or not I
can't tell it's good success yeah we did it are they getting
zapped I can't wait for freedom and for peace are they dying
for freedom and peace bro you don't even have a call what is
going on what now there's an ai generated fire a huge and a
deuce viddas okay um middle east this place is the property
of the conrad family the fbi is investigating is all real
images and this incident how was it how was their fire has
been arrested and is under further investigation oh my god
cyber savant you go george you can go that's the middle
even start where the fuck did the fire come from and also
like when this like when they're getting sapped it was like
got we're like good guys I'm gonna cut the wire now what
about shabu who the fuck is shabu for freedom brother for
freedom The biggest plot hole is the thing about Shabu.
I am so confused.
I- Who is Shabu?
Who the fuck is Shabu?
Oh my god.
Who's George?
Oscar Mather?
I'm sorry, Oscar.
You were trying so hard to save the...
this you know you did amazing oscar kudos to you you were
actually so good you're not the best ass actor in this game
you deserve so much more bro you two you two ryan hannah and
christopher UN how much did they pay you how how much did
they fucking pay you for the sound balancing I I am very
curious it's finally over I will say surprisingly there was
a lot of people working on this game for what we just played
Toki, I think risking the Empress game would have been
better.
Oh my god, there was so...
There's a parkour minigame chose to save George in Texas.
Oh my god.
I stayed up until 6.30 a.m.
for and it was worth it thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you so much thank you welcome to the tomato 5
welcome no guys we are not gonna check the abdullah solomon
all right jack's biological jack's adopted father i actually
had a fucking big Holy shit!
Jack, what's the guy?
The guy that taught him?
Ni hao.
Oh my god.
He led his family in the warriors of Shamu against the power
of the Conrad family.
That's fucking crazy.
Okay, the Shamu kingdom.
A country that existed a thousand years ago.
After being invaded and destroyed, citizens survive odombers
and millennia countless members of the swim cap sac crystals
and okay okay so that's what the okay well we got our
context in the fucking archive wow the lore actually goes so
crazy okay well then that was a game that has to be the most
wild game i've ever played i've managed to trick myself into
playing a, I did not, guys, I did not realize that this was,
I will have to say, I did not realize this was an AI game.
I just thought it was a bad, like, you know, like those
funny, bad FMV games.
I did not realize it would lead us to a journey of
exploration it was truly a game of all time um yeah so like
i know that i didn't i would definitely read the okay so i
did read the ai generated content disclosure and then like
but i didn't really like pay attention to it so i like
looked at like okay i've like only skimmed through it I was
like, oh, okay.
It says, like, all cinematic scenes and character footage
are captured through live action shooting and no
AI-generated content involved.
And I was like, oh, okay.
All right, that's fine.
And then I was like, I didn't realize the extent that they
went through, right?
Because it's like a very small portion of assets in the
mini-games are AI, are AI.
That's literally all it tells me.
It says a small portion of the mini-games are generated.
by ai and then and then they said everything else is real so
i was like okay well the minigames aren't the main focus
here it's obviously the story and i'm like oh i i could do
and then um if you read the reviews it's like it's like yeah
i should have i should have read more in depth of the
reviews because i saw the first one it's like it's a fun
It's fun and it's so bad.
It's good kind of way.
And I was like, you know what?
I fuck with that.
It could be a bad movie watch along that I could play.
And apparently people were saying that the reviews got like,
um, like review bodied.
And I read it.
I was like, it got review bodied.
I was like, oh, that means this is a bad game.
That's going to be fun.
I was just like, oh, that's gonna be fun if it's like, if
it's like review bought it, then it's gonna be a bad game.
I love you, Joki, but damn, this was garbage.
Ni hao, take care.
Solid, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yeah, no, I think in the end, I, it was fun, despite
like, despite what we went through.
It was fun when, like, just fucking going through the
fucking filming.
It's enough of it.
But I will not play a game like this again.
I will say that.
I definitely will not play a game like this again.
Like, if it's, like, fully AI and shit like that.
Because I don't fuck with that.
I only kept going because at that point I was like...
I was past the two hour mark and I was like, I can't get a
refund anymore.
So I'm just going to try and get, I'm just going to see
where this goes.
And I think at that point, we all know that like, this is
not a great game.
I was already too invested and I need to know where this
ends.
That's why I just kept going.
I was like, it passed the two hours.
I can't get a refund anymore.
And like, um, and at that point.
I'm way too deep into this.
I have to know where it ends.
Milk, yeah, milk as much content as you can.
But yes, you could have just played a funny Chinese court
game on Twitch, though.
Keep that trusted.
Thank you.
Give me a super chat.
Yeah, but I just wanted to play something on YouTube,
though.
I wanted to play something on YouTube.
But now, this game is an example of how bad AI is, guys.
AI is not going to replace real human beings when it comes
to like writing as well writing a game um voice acting at
least we know that but like I said I just want you guys just
to be a little disclaimer I don't endorse like these type of
AI um in especially in video games it was just at that point
we I just wanted to know where this goes like we were in too
deep and at that point I think we all knew we were making
fun of the game like We were not endorsing anything at that
like I think we all know I was in all of us were not
endorsing anything we were like just we're just here being
like what else were they gonna do next you know yeah it's
like it was a PSA about the horrors of AI and yeah I just I
just wanted to know like what what we're gonna get next
because like it surprised me and yeah not like we're
everyone like every time a new scene came over i was it i i
thought i i thought i was ready but i was never ready i was
i was definitely never ready for whatever they give me
should probably report the game on steam for lying about ai
usage i mean i'll just i mean i could try and get a refund
because like i do not think when they said a small portion A
small portion of the mini-games are AI And all AI-generic
kind of want to go Secondary opportunization before use But
that's like And I was like But everything else is like not
AI-generated Yeah that's a little bit Oh my god I just
realized The screenshot of the Joker's game Is literally
like If you scroll down They actually recreated They
recreated the Last Supper That's fucking hilarious
they did a photo like they did a photo shoot where they
recreated the fucking last supper with the actors that's
fucking crazy it's on steam it's oh i'll show it to you guys
it's on steam oh my god okay next week we'll play an actual
good fmv but i will not i don't want to i do want to i'll
see if we can find another fmv that won't play on youtube i
don't want to play a game on uh play on twitch uh i'll do
that in the future but next week we'll do an actual good
mffmv also it has by the way this game has 346 very positive
reviews i do not think that's true i i i have a feeling that
um i have a feeling that that is not accurate that's also
how it they got me six very positive reviews and they got me
all right let's see yeah there's no shot
all right let's see where do i save it where the did i save
this i want to show you guys oh there it is all right
screenshots sort by date please i need to show you guys i
have to show you guys the recreation the last separate that
they did with my my boy george my boy georgie he's working
so fucking hard they give him nothing but he's still trying
they actually look they they work he worked so hard they
barely gave anything but he still he still gave it his best
shot It's the last supper.
They actually...
He died for us since.
What was that guy's name again?
Guys, I'm looking him up.
What was his name?
George...
Wait, what was his name was actually George?
What was his name, guys?
Oscar...
Oscar Mather.
oh my god he has an imdb known for grunt work don't come in
and breath
bro he didn't put the i don't think he put the other okay
what's your contact oh my god he trained in europe before
moving to london to work on a rate wait that's not him oh
there he is oh my god he's canadian You are fuck with you,
George.
Guys, he's Canadian.
Bro, he completely...
Okay, guys, I...
I'm not doxing him.
His profile is public.
Guys, he's a biomechanical engineer.
That's crazy.
And then he's like, I'm just...
I won't be inactive.
Yeah, bro.
Bro, oh my god.
He got biomechanical engineering degree.
And then he's like, nah, I'm going to act.
Also, apparently he's really good at soccer.
What the fuck?
Why is that?
Oh, he's a driver's license and a passport.
That's his, it's his like little, um, it's his fucking like,
like, uh, what is it called?
Backstage?
It's where like you find jobs for he's not in a union, too.
That's good.
I mean, that's not good, but then that's good for me.
That's how they got him.
That's how they got George.
Please let there be one bad thing about him.
That's how they were able to get him.
The fucking...
The fucking fee in this game.
Like whatever they paid him.
He's the non-union.
Alright.
One day I'll hire him.
one day I'll hire him.
I don't know for what but one day it'll happen.
I have no idea what I'll do with George.
Don't get the anti-union.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course.
Guys, I'm going to head off now as I had to make a
disclaimer about it because I like in case people are like,
wow, I can't believe she played this game.
She endorses AI.
I did not know and at that point it was too i was just we
can't get a refund and i was just too invested in what we're
getting next i thought it was just i just wanted to know
what crazy adventure this game was gonna bring me in um but
i will be more careful in the future
was funny though like it's it's not surprising it was not
surprisingly but like it was i felt like every time like i
just didn't expect what was coming next but anyway guys i'm
gonna head off now i hope you guys enjoyed the well i don't
know if enjoyed is the right way but i hope you guys had the
time of your lives today at whatever we just played anyway
guys as always everybody hydrated posture check get up and
move around and get that blood flowing you stayed up for me
head to bed because you deserve it i what when will we free
shabu i don't know anyway guys bye everyone bye